hey folks um
welcome uh this is kind of weird um i
was hoping i was gonna be in oslo this
morning at this point in time to
a present in person but uh virtual's
gonna have to work
um so uh for folks who don't know me i
am scott hunter
i'm the director of program management
on the dot-net team at microsoft
um and today i'm here to talk about the
journey21.net
this has been a vision
that a bunch of us on team have shared
for a couple of for a long long number
of years actually
uh but let's get started uh and i've
got a couple surprises uh
i have one demo at the very end that is
a special demo that uh very few people
have seen so
uh you'll be some of the first people to
see it and let's start moving
um
this you know i joined microsoft in 2007
and at that time.net was only able to
really do desktop and web
and then over the years we've added
cloud mobile gaming iot and ai and so we
think it's now a platform that you can
build anything with
um one of the big questions i always get
uh when i talk about.net is
you know what's the health.net
and i'm blessed because because we build
a framework and we build the tools
we have a pretty good grasp of what our
numbers are so
we have over 1.5 million people that are
using.net core today and this is
active monthly not not
download and run one time
uh this is showing the last year's stack
overflow where we were the number one
most loved framework.net core was
this year we were the number one most
loved web framework asp.net core
and the most loved other framework.net
core
um and then you know we open source.net
in 2014
uh which is kind of late uh compared to
most of the competition
uh but it's been good for us we've uh
taken over a hundred thousand uh
community uh prs uh over time
and um we are one of the top 30 highest
velocity oss projects in github
we're the top five language in github
um and performance has been a huge push
in uh the.net core space uh we're seven
times faster than node.js
um we're faster than java
uh we hold our own with things like go
um so you know we're pretty good there
and then
uh as you download and try to use our
software out we actually survey a lot of
folks and
what we find is a lot of folks
trying.net are actually young and
students
um
so you know how are we doing
um you know we're the dot net has been
around for about 18 years at this point
and we've uh
added a million users just last year and
i think it's an amazing feat 18 years in
to still add a million users a year
of those about 600 000 of those were
dynamic core developers
and then
dot net core is the the first version
that we mean we've supported that does
um
support for for linux and mac and
last year we had over a million
publishes
um
uh to the linux folder so
people are actually trying that stuff
out
dot net core three we shipped in uh
september of 2019
uh we shipped 3.1 in december of 2019
and it's the fastest version.net ever if
you've been using.net or looking at.net
over the years
uh our customers typically moved at a
colossal phase three or four or five
years between versions
and when we shipped out net core three
within the first six weeks 75 of our
customers
had actually tried it um and so that's
what we want we want customers to move
forward and stay with us faster
um stack overflow which a lot of
developers use um they migrated to
dynamic core 3.1 uh a few months ago
and uh you know they've seen better
performance uh the the form the
performance was so much better that i
remember nick craver actually uh posting
a tweet saying that
uh some of their systems that monitor
stack overflow reported it being down
when they first switched to dotnet core
3.1 uh because it was returning the
results so fast
that uh the tech thought the site was
airing and so they had to readjust
things because things were so fast
um
so i want to talk about a few things
really quick um that we shipped at the
build conference a few weeks ago
uh that we put on virtually and then
we're going to talk about you know
what's going to happen after dot net
core is 3.1
so
um
just like two weeks ago we shipped uh
blazer web assembly and for those folks
that don't know
blazer is a full stack uh
stack on top of um
a.net core
uh and by full stack i mean it's
basically any blazer app is a spa
application and we shipped blazer server
uh in september of of 2019 along with
dynamic iii and what it did is it
basically made any asp.net app that was
using the laser template into a spa
application
and it does all that by processing on
the server and because of that it's
actually very lightweight
uh when it when it renders a page
and you do an interaction we send the
interaction back to the server it
re-renders and just sends the diff back
to the client and so
it's one of the lightest spa frameworks
you'll ever use
because it doesn't bring down an angular
review react or something like that
uh now
we just announced or shipped blazer
webassembly and that web assembly allows
us to actually run c sharp in your
browser
and so you can actually write c sharp
code in your eraser pages
and it'll actually just run right in the
browser which means you can take
advantage of the local hardware
but it also means you for the first time
can really build a
progressive web application with full
offline support in.net
um because even with with the network
off that c-sharp's running in the
browser it can do stuff it can put stuff
in local storage when it sees the
network come back up they can go
reconnect and uh i might show a little
small demo of some of that code and it's
now in all the.net core 3.1 sdks and it
also comes with visual studio 16.6
i'll demo things in a little bit um
we'll skip that for now um
with dot net core 3 uh and 3.1 we also
brought the last wave of technologies
from.net framework into.net core and
some of those we brought over were win
forms in wpf we still have over
um we have millions of developers that
are actually building these types of
applications and so we wanted to give
people a path forward into.net core
and the big thing that we just shipped
in 16.7 preview 2
is all the toolbox controls and the
designers available
for the customers
uh so this means if you have a winform
application you can now
move it to core
and you can use the uh the winform
designer for pretty much everything
we have third-party controls coming next
that'll be soon by end of the year i
hope um but this is in the box today and
if you drive the preview 2 you get all
the controls
uh and then finally
we we shipped about a year ago at the
build conference
on ml framework for.net called ml.net
and
uh after we shipped it it is uh you know
machine learning is a complex chunk of
attack
um and we wanted to make it easier for
customers to go build apps on top of it
and so we built a thing called model
builder and that's basically a wizard
that sits on top of visual studio
and you can select the workload you want
to do for example
maybe you want to classify images and
that's a demo i have and move my show
you select that you give us the training
data and then we'll go build a model for
you
um and then we'll actually stick it into
your project
um and we'll write the code for you to
actually call and
predict what something is
uh and you can just paste that into your
application and you're good to go and
you can really get started in in under
10 minutes with this pack uh and i still
highly recommend it so all three of
these things the
blazer web assembly
the um
model builder and the winform designer
are all in the bits that just came out
um as i said we'll do a few demos in a
little bit
uh skip the demo for now
um and so it leaves us at a point where
uh what we really tell customers is if
you're a net developer
and you're gonna build a brand new
application now is the time to build it
on top of.net core
dyna core 3.1 has long term support
which means it's going to it's good for
three plus years of support
it's got wpf and winforms brought over
to make it easier to port your
applications
if you want it's got full side-by-side
support you can have as many versions of
decor on the machine that you want and
they won't break each other um and you
can now both self-contained x's so if
you want to go build a
asp.net app or a winform app and make it
into a single exit that does not require
any dotnet on the machine you can now do
that
uh we have awesome modern spa web tech
with blazer
and a bunch of cool language features
and so that's
3.1 now
one final thing on on this wave of stuff
is
whether you're using wpf or winforms or
blazer
we have some awesome partner companies
that build awesome tools devexpress and
logistics radzen grape city progress
telerik fusion
i just want to call them out and they
are also helping us on the journey to
getting the third party control support
for the winform designer
now
this is where it's fun for me uh we call
this the journey to one.net
um one of the jokes that i like to make
is
when i joined microsoft
we had already made a lot of dot nets
there was a net framework obviously it
was the first one that we shipped
and we liked it so much that we made
crazy products like windowsserver.net
which didn't contain.net you had to go
download.net separately so but we still
called the windowserver.net
um then we had compact framework
silverlight
there was windows phone
and then of course there's mono which is
an open source version of net before we
open source design ourselves
um and then so the kind of joke for me
is you know i'm scott hunter and i work
for scott guthrie and scott hanselman
works for me so obviously there are ways
to be successful at microsoft or either
to be called scott
um or make a new.net um and so and and
uh you know it was my team that that
went and created.net core a couple years
ago
um but now that we've done that uh what
we'd like to do is um you know
we're looking and thinking about you
know net core 4.0 would be the next
version and we already have a.net
framework 4.8 that felt kind of weird
and so what we'd like to do is basically
say that moving forward we've already
taken the best of document framework in
3.1 and mutual four
we want to take the
uh tech from xamarin and mono the best
of that and move it into net core and
then we're going to rebrand the entire
thing to net 5 because dot net 5 is
bigger than dot net 4.
um but there's a bunch of cool things
that that happen along this dot net 5
and 6 what we're going to call wave
because all the features don't fit into
that net 5 we need two versions of this
but one of these is a single sdk and
what i mean by single sdk is
um you can build any of those app types
i should before
web cloud mobile desktop
um
iot
ml gaming all with a single sdk we're
going to make this sdk super small
meaning it's only going to contain
console apps and class library by
default and you'll have to actually run
a command.net install asp.net or down to
install desktop to add the components
you want we don't want to be a big
bloated framework
um it's got one bcl
uh today if you build a xamarin
application you're using the mono bcl if
you build a a win from applications on
core you're using the.net core bcl we
want to have the exact exact same base
class libraries the strings and dates
and stuff like that so your code is
super portable across all those
different platforms we want to have a
single unified tool chain if you've
tried dot net core it's got command line
tools like
dotnetrun.netbuild.net new
uh we want all the app types to work in
that model
uh we want to have awesome crafts
platform ui uh and i'll talk about that
a little bit later on
um we want to have awesome
cross-platform web ui we already have
some of that today with the blazer web
assembly and blazer server
and our traditional web apis and user
pages and nvc
um we want to have awesome support for
what we call cloud native you know we've
all heard kubernetes or docker
[Music]
containers all these words what do they
mean
and i'll do a demo in a little bit and
show you some of that
and then of course we're always looking
to make net better when it comes to the
speed it runs
the size on disk uh the diagnostics for
you to debug and check your applications
we want to make sure it works awesome in
the cloud that we build here um and i
think that when we in in this wave of
dot net five and six we will basically
be best of breed in every one of those
app types i mentioned before cloud web
mobile uh desktop um iot
uh ml and gaming
now what is what does cloud native mean
uh cloud native means a lot of things to
us it means
uh linux
i'm on a windows machine right now and
if i'm going to be building containers
that are going to run in in linux in the
cloud i want to be able to develop on
linux and so
with a windows subsystem for linux
that's a feature we just we just shipped
a new version of this wcl2 shipped in
windows 2 windows 10 2004 that just
shipped a few weeks ago
you can just run linux natively on a
windows device and we've built the tools
into our tools so you can actually f5
and control f5 from visual studio
directly into linux
um
smaller microservices we hear that
microservices are supposed to be small
so they can be deployed faster and so
we've done a lot of work on being able
to make.net smaller from version
diversion and i'll show you some of that
in a demo and then the biggest one i
think the coolest one here is
uh opini opinionated microservices um
you know if you want to go build you
know three back-end apps uh a redis
cache and a front-end how do you run and
start all that stuff and so we have a
cool uh project called project high that
goes there
and then we're also building a you know
we we want the perfect.net to always be
awesome so we're building a high
performance reverse proxy called yarp uh
that actually will run a bunch of the
azure services and that's how we're
using.net
inside of microsoft
to push and test the limits of
so
um
i'm going to skip this slide and just
right here and let's go do a couple
demos i will say that some of the demos
i'm going to do today are going to be
based on i'm going to play videos and
some are going to be on a local machine
when i was at the build conference a few
weeks ago i had the luxury of having
like three computers and uh i don't want
to jump between three computers here
on a virtual conference so
let's jump out and show a few of these
things
so the first one of these i'm going to
show is i'm going to show
um
running uh w self two
so
you just do this
and what i'm gonna do here is do file
new project
and i'm gonna select that i wanted an
asp.net core web application and click
new and i'm going to call this web app
linux
i guess we're going to run this on linux
and click create here
and i'll just do a regular web
application i could containerize this
right now but i don't want to i'm going
to wait
and show that i don't even have to
containerize anymore to run on linux
so we're gonna let this create here
and i will come over to the pages folder
and let's open up
index.cshtml and i'm gonna put an h2 in
here right here
and i'll just do um
environment.os version to show that
version
and let's just run it real quick
and when i run this what's going to
happen is obviously it's going to launch
the browser
and it's going to do it exactly what i'd
expect it's going to show that i'm
running on builds 100 19041
uh windows that's the 2014 build
um but i have something new here i'm
going to drop down my list here and i
have w cell 2 in this list
i'll zoom in and show you this
and um what i can do here is i can
select that
and now just as fast i've got i've got
to accept the search here
just as fast as it was on
running on windows
now it's launching kestrel
and the os version now shows i'm running
on unix
and that's 4 1984 i'm running ubuntu
right here
super easy super fast not only can i run
native linux on my windows machine i can
put a breakpoint here and we can run the
debugger
from windows directly into that wsl
2 environment
so there i am the breakpoint hits
and you can see things just work
and so we're going to make it that easy
to develop on linux on your windows
machine
i'm sure one more thing here we've
actually done a lot of work to make the
container tools a lot better and so i
can come down here and say add
docker
and i can choose my os in this case
we're doing linux stuff so let's do
linux here
and i'll click ok
and what we can do is notice i have a
docker file that's the only thing that's
in my project used to add a bunch of
other stuff and it's a fancy docker file
there's the base image to run on top of
um it's actually running the background
getting things free from right now so i
strive to be fast the first time
notice here that i've got uh an sdk so
to do a build and then i copied that
version into my real container
um and so i'm publishing to a small
container that does not contain the sdk
and once again i can come up and run
this application
and now
it will launch
once again accept the cert
there we go um and now it's running on
top of docker the same unix version
there as well i can open up my command
prompt
and do a docker ps dash a and now you
can see that i'm running on uh and
containers
and so you can see how fluid it is for
me to move between
uh containers
um and wcl2
and all this stuff so we think this is a
gonna be awesome uh
for developers to be able to do this
this easy
i'm gonna show one more video and then
we'll do two
uh demos that are um on my machine
some of these are videos as well because
you have to use the crazy machine
configuration for this i'm gonna show
c-sharp nine here and show one of my
favorite features here i've got a an app
here and notice this app almost has no
no code in it there's no user there's no
main
um if i wanted to i could even nuke the
using
um and put that right in front of my
console.writeline if i wanted to
um
let's run it first there you go it runs
now i'll go nuke that out there we go
that up system dot
um and this is the intensity being able
to make very easy c sharp programs that
don't have a bunch of ceremony in them
but i can make this even cooler let me
go over and change
my cs proj file and i'll change my sdk
from the regular sdk to the web sdk
which brings asp.net in
and what we're trying to do here is is
try to make it easy to build a micro
service in a small line a small small
number of lines as possible so i'm going
to nuke a bunch of white space here
and here is a sub 20 line
dot net micro service uh the notion
that.net requires you to have tons of
files and tons of stuff
is not true anymore
um a single file here
um
i can run this it'll still run
launch my browser there you go we plan
to take this tech even further in the
long run i hope is make it to the point
where i don't even have to have the cs
project and actually just run the c
sharp file dot net run name of the cs
the cs file um and even simplify the way
that you can build
um
absent.net
so always trying to make less lines of
code smaller simpler
um
compared to our competitors now let me
show you something really cool here so i
was talking about microservices i talked
about size on disk a single xe in my
slide here
i'm gonna go
here
and what i do is i have i have uh two
folders here
uh one's called single single file three
one
this is running the regular three one
bits and this might be using some
features you're not aware of
first off
notice i have a
i say publish single file true
that means we're telling the the
sdk to basically make a single legacy
that contains all the.net core it does
not require anything to be on the
machine it's a single legacy i tell it
to be
published trimmed equals true
it tells it to basically strip out all
the.net core that i don't need and make
me the smallest thing possible and
because i'm doing a single legs you have
to tell it you know it needs to know if
it's linux or windows or mac and so i
have to tell it
that so let's run that
and this will come through here
and this will end up with a micro
service that's about
45 mhm
thank you thank you thinking
um
[Music]
i might cheat while this is waiting
there it goes
um this does take a little bit longer
because of the linker uh just trying to
throw stuff away
there we go
and if i go look in that folder now
let's go into the bin folder
release
add core31 when x64 publish
here is my
roughly
45 meg microservice i still think that's
not too bad um if you build some of
these apps with like the java jdk or
something like that you're going to be
in a much bigger space but we can do
better
so i have another folder here
and inside of this i'm running the exact
exact same commands except i'm running
on.5
and so let's run this again
and it's running as the exact same stuff
um except we can we will continue to
work on the linker and making this deck
better as we move forward
notice it's telling me that it could
change the behavior of the app to link
her by throwing stuff away if it throws
too much away your app could break and
we have ways to fix that
but you should be aware of that
if i go back down and look at my folder
here
let's go into the bin folder release
and x64 is going to publish folder
now look at this
this is now 17 megs
so we went from 45 megs to 17 mags
that's a huge savings
and
i always like to prove that
it's real
let's go into the publish folder here
there is that 17-megaxi
and if i run it
it should come up
i'll launch the browser
the app is running and so that's showing
you that we
are going to continue to make
investments to make the size these apps
on disk smaller and smaller we want to
apply this as well to desktop apps so
you can make really small desktop apps
that don't have any dot net on the
machine like i said this this exit i
could copy it on a memory stick to any
machine it would just run and so that
shows you the investment we're trying to
make in single file
now
let me close a couple of these things
out here
don't need that
let's talk about project tie this is one
of my favorite
uh pieces
of the
tech we're doing when it comes to
uh microservices so i'm gonna go back to
my terminal
and i've got an app here uh let's just
do a dur
you see i've got a backend folder and i
got a front-end folder
and i'll launch this up in vs code
there we go
um and
for this application let's let's say i
just want to run it there's there's a
bunch of challenges running with running
on net applications that have you know a
lot of different projects inside of them
uh in visual studio there's a mechanism
where you can launch more than one
project at the same time you can right
click on your solution and say uh
launch multiple projects just a bunch of
problems that come with that
um and i'll explain some of those in
just a second so if i want to run this
app today what i have to do is go over
here
i'm in the front end folder and i can do
a net run
we'll give this a chance to boot up here
there we go
and i'll launch the app
in the browser here
and of course um
this isn't going to run
and it's because i forgot to start the
back end i need i need to remember to
run both projects
uh which is actually kind of hard to do
from vs code
uh you get to build a special command
that
launches both of the projects yourself
now i've got the back end running
you know the app kind of hooks up but we
can do better than this
so let's close it
and i'm going to close this folder out
let's close this folder out
um and what we've created is something
called tie and the idea of tie is it
lets you type projects together and so i
can do tie run
at the top of my my folder here and what
it's going to do is it's going to go
scan all the folders and find all the cs
projects
and it's going to run
them and it's going to give me more than
that when i when i ran those those other
projects before
there's a whole bunch of things i could
not have done so let's go here
and launch this up
and now when i run multiple projects
i'm getting a dashboard dashboard tells
me hey i found two projects i found a
front-end project and backend project
their projects meaning their cs projects
and it gives me a path to the cs proj um
for each of those projects i can now see
the urls for the projects and just click
them to open the browser
i can go look at the logs
for each of these projects running
here and here
um i can even go over here and if i
click on this i can go see some of the
performance counters
for that particular project this is
stuff that you never would have seen
before
uh just running things from the command
line now this is still not going to work
um and that's because my app's not set
up correctly and if i click this
i'm going to get a failure that it can't
find the back end because it does it
doesn't know what the port is
there we go
no connection could be made because the
target machine actually refused it so
let's let's close that out and i'm going
to stop tai for a second
um i'm stopping and starting thai
uh the latest release of thai that just
came out
this week i believe
does supports thai run watch where
you can start it and then as you change
your source code files it'll reboot that
part for you automatically without
having to go back and start and stop but
let's
let's go in here
and this is my frontend project and
notice that today
it actually hard codes the uh url for
the backend
we do have a file launch
settings.json that you can actually have
in your
[Music]
applications to
configure these these types of things
but even then making all those ports
match and stuff if you get to put that
in source control it's just not good we
can do better so let me let me tie if i
this project so i'm going to go in here
it's my cs proj file and i'm going to
actually uncomment a package this is
something that would be just built
into.net in the future and this is a
configuration extension so yeah sure
restore that for me
um and what that lets me do is i go to
my startup file here and and now instead
of having this hard-coded url
i can just say
um
base address equals configuration get
service uri backend you saw before those
things were called back-end and
front-end what type will do for me is
when it boots these things up it
actually will inject an environment
variable into each of those processes
with the actual correct port numbers and
so i can just tell my app use the vacuum
to use the front end and all that port
mapping is done automatically this is
super important when you get to
something like kubernetes or docker
where those ports change based on the
environment you're running in now with
tie because we're flowing that
configuration information directly into
the processes you don't have to worry
about that so if i
save this
and i come back over here and i do a tie
run again
now everything's going to work
just go here let it run
there we go
and i can just go back to my dashboard
i can refresh the dashboard
there's my application
click the uri
everything just works
this is great
um but we can do so much more again so
i'm going to close out that window
stop this one more time
and what i'm going to do is
go back to my uh
prompts here and i'm going to type tie
init
so before i mention that when i ran
tyron it went and figured out what cs
files were there maybe i want that to be
the actual configuration that i can
change by typing tie knit
um oops
it's going to go
and create a file for me let's go back
to my vs code
and here's the thai yaml file and notice
it basically does all the things that it
was self-discovering for me is now in
textual format you can see that i've got
we're calling it microservice it's got a
front end with a cs branch a back in
with the cs proj and what's cool here is
i can come to my uh notepad here and i'm
going to add a little bit of goop
i'm going to go and just stick this over
here
and what i just did is i added two more
services inside of my tie
uh yaml file
uh the first one is it's it's got a name
called res and notice instead of being a
project
instead of being a project this is now a
image
and what that means is that means
container image and so what it's going
to do for that is it's going to go pull
the container
out of the container registry and put it
on my machine
uh and it's basically going to run
reddit so i'm without installing redis
on my machine i now have redis in this
project in fact i run redis twice
once to run as itself and then once
again to run it as a monitor and so my
my application is now dockerified it can
run i can put sql server in in this way
i could put postgres in this way there's
tons of things i could put in this way
now now that i've done that
let's go use the redis cache before i
open it up so i'm going to go back into
the cs proj here
i'm going to comment out one more thing
let's comment this out
this is the package reference uh to the
microsoft caching the stack exchange
redis
and this is important i need this
because
i'm going to go to my um
startup cs
and i'm going to add
doctor support
so this is add stack to change redis
cache
and it says basically i need to
configure this i'm going to basically
inject the uh the redis cache into the
di on the machine
um and notice once again i didn't figure
out i didn't put ports in here
i basically just said get connection
string redis because once again we're
gonna
do all that stuff for you and the right
ports will show up there and i don't
have to worry about that as things
change
and then let's go to my
index.cshtml
and i have a tag helper in here
um
and one that we we built
and distributed cache i give my cache
name weather
and then i say
you know after five seconds i want the
cache to expire
uh it's gonna squiggle because i need to
come in here and comment the closing of
the tag
save that
and now we've added redis cache to our
application i didn't write any docker
files i don't know how to write docker
files
um
i added a package to enable the
redis cache support in.net core i wrap
my my code and a tag helper
that does caching for me automatically
and now if i go back to my command
prompt and i run tyron again
uh the outputs can be a little different
because a lot more stuff's going to
happen here
so now i can see running docker command
running image redis running image
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
here
um wow that's kind of kind of
interesting
let's go back to my dashboard let's do a
refresh here
and now
i've got four projects
and two of them
are containers
the cool thing here is i said i didn't
write docker files i didn't write
uh
home charts or any kind of stuff i just
said i want an image give it a port
it's ready to go
i can go back to my front end
application
and if i start refreshing the screen
that nothing changes it just changed
it's been five seconds
just changed again it's been five
seconds
so you can see that it actually is
caching that cache work is working here
just like i wanted i can come back over
here um let's go look at the logs
and you can see all the all the uh cache
hits
uh that are happening here
it was glitchy for some reason
you know why it was not cooperating
cash was working and i'm just not seeing
the logs
weirdo
um
but still not good enough let me let me
close uh the app out again
and i want to show one final thing
um you know now i've built an
application it's got uh
two apps that are running normally uh on
my machine i've got two apps that are
running in uh containers
if i'm gonna really run this in
kubernetes or in the cloud and as
containers
everything's going to run as a container
if i do tyron
help
notice that there is a
dash dash docker command i can run and
so if i do that
let's say docker
now all of my apps are going to run
inside of containers and so this puts me
in the state i want to be in
uh to actually publish this up to
something like azure kubernetes service
because
all the pieces are going to run
containers in that world
um and so
before i get ready to publish and and do
that i can test it right here
if i go back to my cs project file again
right back to my dashboard again and i
refresh
now notice everything is turned into a
container
just that easy
um if i click the link over here it
works just like it did before now i'm
running in containers using docker
and so that's that it's just amazing how
easy this stuff is now why this was
important
is because the next step i could do
is what if i wanted to publish this to
the cloud what what is my step to do
well my step to do is to go back to my
[Music]
his code
and i will go back to that yaml file
and all i'm going to do is grab
this right here
and
uh before i get the services i'm going
to basically say registry
bill 2020 tie that azure cr i o i'm
giving it basically a container registry
that i have then i own
um and then
i can go back to my command prompt and
i just type time
uh notice i have a command here called
deploy
and so literally i could just do tie
and this application
will
publish up to the azure container
registry
and be there and if i have triggers set
up in like kubernetes um it'll notice i
put new images in it'll pull them and
then because all that port mapping magic
i showed you before you don't have to
worry about all the networking
challenges between all these different
applications running in kubernetes and
i'm showing all this in the context of
vs code and command prompt but we're
going to make this go through visual
studio as well you're going to have an
awesome experience to run
multi-app
net applications in vs or vs code
as i said this text already better i'm
not running it because i'm not going to
change my machine uh the day of running
something but i could have done
something like this
and it would watch my code changes and
just restart it automatically for me and
give you that great interlude to expect
and net this is
um and i think it's one of the most
exciting things that we're doing
um and so that's that
so let's get back here and let's talk
about cross-platform native ui
um this is a
thing people been asking us for for
years
and so let's talk about that
so i want to introduce what we're going
to call net multi-platform app ui
um and this will make sense called
multi-platform app ui because you can
have a single project
that can run on ios android windows and
mac
uh maybe in the future on linux as well
uh but you can see basically this is
dotnet maui
that's the abbreviation of.net
multi-platform app ui and it runs on.net
and it has a couple of things that it
cares about one is
cross platform native native ui um we
want to do that
uh the new thing if you're a xamarin
developer today
uh you might have seen that the xamarin
project um will typically have an
android project it'll have an ios
project it'll have a windows project
potentially
it'll have a shared class library
a lot of moving parts we just want to
have that be a single project and from
that just right click and deploy to what
you want
um so deploy to multiple devices mobile
and desktop just right click on the
project and say run it on my iphone or
run it on my windows device make that
really easy
this is an evolution of xamarin forms
we're really taking the xamarin tech
and as we
unify.net into what we call one.net
um it's it's just part of the the stack
and it's going to target.net six and
we'll have previews later this year
around the rc time.net five
uh we'll have previews of this available
on github that you can try
and you can look today in kidhop.com.net
maui there's stuff there today uh um
about how we build this what does it
look like
um
from the code
um notice that before we would have had
xamarin.forms that's now system.ui we
used to have xamarin.essentials that's
now system.devices you can tell me
these texts that used to feel like they
might have been outside of.net are now
in dotnet file new is the
multiplatformappui dotnet and then for
the first time ever you've got a cli.net
new maui
what do we do for the rest of the
xamarin project
uh we're gonna rebrand the projects so
it's just.net for ios.net for android um
the namespaces change the same stay the
same but you'll also notice
uh they're all using the new sdk style
that we have in the dot-net core
projects
and you have net new ios and done a new
android so we we think this unifies the
xamarin technology directly into
um dotnet
um and i'm super excited about it
and so let's do a quick demo of
maui
so i'll go back here
and we'll first run it on a mac and show
a couple things you never could have
done before
so here i am on the mac i'm going to
make a folder called maui
and i'll jump into that folder and for
the first time ever i can do a net new
maui
um you've never been able to build the
xamarin app from the command line now
you can
um and i'll do an ls here to show you
there's the ios android we don't have
the single project working on this build
yet
but let me go into uh do a quick restore
and then we'll launch ps code
after the restore
and i'll show you some of the new tech
that we have in maui
so let's do a code dot
and here's my project
i'm going to drill into the maui folder
here let's go to the main page does yes
and um
first thing you might notice here is
there is no xaml here this is actually
written in c sharp
um so we are going to give you an mdu
c-sharp model uh to build your ui and
native c-sharp if you want
uh let me show you something else new
right from vs code i can launch the
inter the ios simulator here
pop it up here
uh app is building
um and i'm gonna show you some features
called hot reload and hot restart
they're pretty amazing
um it says app's going to go up to my
phone here
there it is
uh install and let's click that
and
when the app launches
i'll just click the plus button you can
see the value increments
um now i want to change the code that
that label should not actually be
stuck over there where it is um so you
look at the code here i'm gonna go fix
that text alignment i'm gonna type dot
center here
now i'm not gonna rebuild or do anything
i didn't even save i just did center and
it moved to the center
um so we're making an inner loop really
fast to make the color pink
boom it's pink
i'm not a big fan of pink myself so i'm
gonna go back to black
back to black
um if i want let's go change some of
that source code i'm gonna change the uh
the plus plus to a minus minus
like that and i'll just press the plus
button down there it never goes
backwards i need to fix that plus button
too
let's go over here and change the code
here
now the label changes
and so what you can see is how easy it
is to build an application
in.net
with maui
with this new nvu pattern write all your
ui and c-sharp
if you want so let me
make this go away
we'll do one more maui demo here this is
now running on windows
and you'll see me here there's there's
that new template
um i'm not going to create that i'm just
going to close this out and i'm going to
open another vs that has a maui project
inside the memory project and this time
i want to show
even though i showed you that brand new
c sharp you don't have to use that new c
sharp um you know we are the xamarin
customers are very used to xaml
uh we have the same xml support we've
always had here and so you can see i've
got my stack layout i've got my
thermal bindings here um and so we're
gonna make it super easy for you to move
uh from xamarin.net maui
staying in uh xaml if you want to
uh of course you can also write ui in
that new c sharp let's do something else
here
i'm just going to run this on windows
i want this interlude to be super fast i
don't want to write an emulator or
anything like that if i'm on a mac i
want to run on the mac i'm on the
windows i'm just running on windows
you can see the diagnostic tools boot up
here the app is running
boom um and so once again we want to
make the the default for building these
apps super super fast and so
you can run the app natively on the
device you're
you're designing it on
without having to worry about using an
emulator
now
i mentioned before we added a feature
called hot reload and hot restart it's
already in visual studio today for
xamarin projects and what it does is it
allows me to just basically plug my
iphone into my pc
and just have it work i didn't have to
install any weird stuff
i don't even have to have anything more
than a free apple developer kit account
i can get a developer.apple.com
i plug my phone in
it's going to show up here in the list
as scott's iphone
i will click that
um and this tech as i said is super
amazing i've got a a copy of um let's
deploy it to the iphone
i've got a copy of uh reflector running
down here that's an app that actually
will mirror my iphone
on the pc
and here it is and i can run the app
uh on my phone now i also want to call
out that as i'm doing this
i don't have to have a mac anywhere in
the system for development i can
actually do it just with the windows
machine and a free apple developer
accounts and just works without
installing anything on my device at all
just plug the device in and it goes
and i think that's super exciting
you do have to have a mac to deploy to
the actual application store
but if you have a team of 20 you only
need one mac
um now this is what's really cool this
is a single project notice this it's uh
if you you're used to xamarin you would
have had a couple of projects here
now i've i've locked this down to a
single project it's got a resource node
obviously i need a place to share my
icons there's my favorite.net bots
icon
and i can now share that across you know
windows mac
ios and android
i can also put things like fonts in here
uh because i want to have my own fonts
or my apps they look good
on my devices so there's a couple of my
fonts
now i do want to say the the coolest i
think node in this project is
the platform node
and so if i scroll up here
uh and drop this down
uh you're going to see basically i've
got a folder for
android ios and windows and that's where
i would write code it only runs on that
on those platforms so
once again the bluetooth
adapter
is code that is hard coded to the actual
uh apis on the individual platforms so
once again we give this single project
that runs all your applications you can
run with no emulator you can easily plug
your devices in and have them work and
that's net maui
and i think that's super exciting stuff
um
i'm gonna do one more maui demo here
real quick um and this is a crazy demo
of where we think things could be going
in the future so
let me do this
um and this is a maui app back in my app
i'm gonna run it on my device here
and what's going to happen when i do
that is
it'll
open here
there it is
and um this is a native native native
app native ui so
push the button does the thing
native controls um deploy all your
devices now how can i make this cooler
um
there's this notion of apps that people
built a day where
they're called hybrid and that's a mix
of web tech and a mix of native native
tech
a lot of folks use things like react
native for that kind of stuff
um but what i've got here is i'm going
to basically
nuke some stuff here
and now i'm going to actually take my
native app
and i'm going to blazer webview inside
of it
and uh
run this
here is the app again and now that's my
web code
and my native controls on the same app
things still work and you might be going
scott this is not really true this is
your fakedness this is actually laser
which means i can write c sharp inside
of here
let's do this
write a for loop here i need to put a p
tag here
and display that number there
and run this one more time
now you can see that not only is that
web that web actually is running my
c-sharp
you can see the markup there
just like you would expect
um but i can make it even cooler
let me just
like that
and i'll comment this out
and let's let's go to a slightly
different version of this i've got
another one here
and this case
um this is a blazer webview
but it's gonna actually talk to the same
state the native controls are talking to
up here notice when i
click the button we call
counterstate.increments
and when i displayed the number it was
counter state that current count you can
see i injected
uh the counter state into this
page
in this case
my blazertech is calling the exact same
counter state.current and the exact same
counter state that increment counts if i
run this application now
what's going to happen
it's complaining that i never close the
other app
be kind close the app scott
there we go
and so now i have a mix of native app
native tech webtech in the same app i
press increment they both change because
we're sharing state across the
boundaries
share this across the two boundaries i
can go all the way
let's
hide that out
and now what i'm basically doing here is
i'm putting a web view in saying
show me my entire web ui for my my uh
blazer app
so i've got my native ui up here at the
top
and i have a full blazer
application running in the bottom
and i'll tell you why this is important
in just a second
so here we are
now you see the full blazer app running
here
i've got my native stuff at the top here
it's got the fetch data you would expect
all this tech running together in the
same application
uh notice the counters are still hooked
up we're sharing state across the native
boundary and the web boundary
um and so you might ask you know
why scott what what's the point of this
deck
this is us taking a look at uh you're
all familiar with electron apps
that's where you take a native
shell and you actually run some some
web technology inside of it this is
doing the same thing with net
i took maui down at maui and used it as
my native shell
um and inside of it i can host a web
view
uh where i can run a blazer application
because this is a native application it
means that laser app now has access to
the actual operating system
um like an electron app can so
it can open up a file you could do all
the things you would expect a desktop
style application to do so
this is an experiment at this point
but it is something i think as we get
towards the end of the dot net five wave
uh you'll see us take this experiment
a step further
um
and turn it into reality so let me close
this out
and i'm super excited about uh all the
dotted and maui stuff
and uh
what we can
how far we can take it
um so where we kind of are today we have
previews of.net 5 out you know once
again.net is completely side by side
which means you can install.net 5 on a
machine with net core 3.1 on it won't
break anything you should be good
um you can start checking out these
cloud native improvements that i talked
about single file you can go grab a
preview of project tie
to go try that uh cool way of building
applications and as i said in just a few
months
when the first uh
dotnet.6 branch is open you'll be able
to grab
dotnet maui in preview and try that out
we just shipped preview five
this week i've gotten at five you can
try that out now
and
a lot of folks ask me what about uwp
uh uwp stands for you know universal
windows programs
and it was it was a model that uh was
shipped a couple years ago people have
always asked scott when did you when is
uwp coming to core
and the answer is it's not going to come
to court uh and that's because the
windows team has announced when ui3
it's the evolution of uwp
it basically gives you
the ability to build awesome windows 10
desktop applications
taking advantage of all the touch
features all that kind of stuff all the
stuff you got uwp but it's different it
doesn't require
a sandbox to run in
it doesn't require the the app store you
can actually just copy one of these
applications to a machine
and all the features work on our
versions of windows 10. um it supports
net5 and cfos plus and you can grab it
today and try it at
aka.mslashwin ui
and we'll continue to make that work
better and better
as we go forward
the next thing i want to talk about is
the schedule um
you know you might ask why did i call
this the.net 5
n6 wave
i i did that because
um
we inaudible to be very consistent to
our developers
we want you to know when the next
version is coming we want you know how
long the support is and never be guessed
by going oh you shipped it in march this
year and then this year in november this
year
uh we want to have a clear cadence uh we
actually got this idea from other open
source projects like ubuntu and node.js
that do the same thing predictable
so net5 will ship this november
um and you can see there's a major
release every single year
and every other year is a long term
support so if you want to stay on 3.1
you can stay on it technically until
november of 2022
and then at that point you would want to
move to dotnet six and you could stay on
it until november of 2024
so you have roughly uh three plus years
of that support cycle but the point here
is we want to be very predictable very
easy for you to know what's coming
um it also helps things like azure and
amazon and other cloud services to know
what our schedule is and have these
runtimes available
for you in those things
and then i want to talk about.net conf
as well
this is our virtual conference where we
launch uh the next versions of our
products
uh and so this year
kind of giving away the.net 5 release
date it's going to be november 10th
uh because that's the day that.netconf
starts
that'll be the launch of dot net five
it's a three day virtual event um it's
half done by uh people on my team and
microsoft
um and it's half done by the community
uh so it's kind of a
thing and
save the date put on your calendars um
the dub dot net conf dot net is open
today you can go check things out
and with that
i'll do one more quick demo because i've
got five minutes left to use all the
time we have
um and i'll do this one on my machine
uh so let me do this i'm gonna go and
open a vs here
and
let's
open up this one um i want to show the
model builder that we have for doing air
reel real quick
if i move it in four minutes
but what i can do is i can take a net
project
and
i'm not going to run it because i don't
have time
and if i want to add ai to it i can just
say
add machine learning
and then we give you a bunch of choices
of machine learning topics
in this case for this app i want to do
image classification so i'm going to
select image classification
um like that
and it needs data you have to train the
model so i'm going to go click here
and i have
ml.net here
and car damage train
um and that's good
and so for image classification that's
when you ask it to say what is this
image is it a broken car is it a
good-looking car what is it we have two
folders here damaged and not damaged
each with 920 images in it
um then what i do is i go and say train
and i can actually train locally on my
machine or train in the cloud i've
actually done this already
closed out of this went this vs i'm
going to the one that i've trained
already you see it's got a 91 accuracy
um and what i'll do is i'll do um
evaluate
at this point if i wanted to i could
test that model i could drag a picture
of a wrecked car or not wrecked car
over here and it would tell me uh if
they thought they were erected or not
but where it gets cool
is i can say
add projects and so when i do that
now i have a
console project project that showed up
and i have a model project that showed
up in my visual studio over here and
then it gave me some code that's
required to go and hook that up so it
works
in this case i've actually got my app
ready to go
i'm just going to go up here
and do this in two minutes
i'm coming out the model
um to actually detect what if the car is
wrecked or not all i do is i basically
say
model.predict
i give it the file path of the image of
the car
that i've taken picture of the car i've
taken
and it returns a result
and all i gotta do here is say
give me the prediction is damaged
and give me the score
so let's save that
let's run the app
this is a blazer application that you
could use at a car rental facility when
a car comes in to be checked in
let's get this up and running
i need the dashboard
and i'll sign in real quick
and nick in the app and now i'd check my
car in i'm going to check in uh 102
here we go and in my case
look here
door's in bad shape
at this ugly picture
my ml model
i can now click detect so i i can just
take a picture of the car with my my
phone
oh no i crashed
um
tried to rush too fast um
what that what that model would
typically do is actually go and make
that call dynamically for me
uh and tell me if that's good or bad
and i would be good to go
but
almost all the time so i'm going to stop
and not debug it here on the stage
with that said
[Music]
net core 3.1 lts is available today
it is all new.net projects should be
built on this
it's got all the new features it's ready
for full production
think about that at the same time if you
want to try the.net 5 stuff we've been
working on
try to give us some feedback
uh you can grab that today
and with that said i just want to say
thank you for having me at ndc oslo this
year
i wish i could be there in person
um but i definitely hope to see if i can
come back next year and be there in
person
thank you folks very much
good morning hello my dear friends well
you're close enough to be called friends
we're about as far away from each other
as everyone else is at the moment
welcome to this talk on the final day of
ndc
if you're still in bed and you're still
watching from bed i hope you're very
comfortable and even if you're not i
still hope that you are as comfortable
as you can be on this beautiful morning
at least here in oslo the weather is
stellar and it's a lovely day so
let's make it just as lovely in here
talk is about getting your feet wet with
open source about getting started and
the intended audience is people who are
quite new to open source at all that
means that if you're a veteran
contributor if you've been around the
block two three four five times
you might not have a lot to learn right
here however please do stick around
because you might pick up a thing or two
and if nothing else maybe you can teach
me something
during the talk i cannot see anyone all
i've got is my feed and my face and my
slides
so that means
if you've got a question or anything
because i don't have a chat ask it in
the slack for conference room 1 and i
will try to get to it at the end of the
presentation
so
how about we actually get started
let's start by
why am i telling you about this and who
am i
my name is thomas hartman and
these are all my socials if you want to
get in touch with me reach me here there
is nothing else on this slide and that
is because
there's nothing notable to put here
i am
very ordinary to put it that way
just a year ago i graduated university
and got properly into programming i had
never done any of it before starting
university
so that means i'm still very very new
and that is exactly why
i
am speaking about this because i haven't
been around for ages i still remember
what it's like to be new i am still new
i still struggle with all these things
that i'm going to talk about
and so
it's easier to teach yourself or you
didn't know five minutes ago than it is
to teach yourself or you didn't know
five years ago because your frame of
reference is so different and so that's
why
i'm talking about this as i mentioned
here are my socials if you can't reach
me on slack because from what i hear
the slack
team will be shut down after the
conference
do try and reach me on twitter or
anywhere else
and
if you want to read some stuff about
tech
i've got a blog too so as everyone else
does right
but let's actually get started with this
and if we're going to talk about open
source
and contributing we've got to first talk
about what it is
and get some sort of definition on the
go but
that might not be super easy
because it's open source it means it's
not actually governed by any real body
however
the open source initiative or the osi
for short
have a definition that's generally
generally regarded as the de facto
definition
the osi is
an organization a non-profit
organization that have for over 20 years
been working to raise awareness and
adoption of open source software and
they are also behind the
urlopensource.org
now
their definition says that open source
doesn't just mean access to the source
code the distribution terms of open
source must comply with a set of
criteria
now this set of criteria is
fairly long not very long it's about 10
or so bullet points
but
in our case and for this talk it's much
too stringent because all that we care
about in this talk are two things
number one
the source code must be available
somewhere online
and number two
the maintainers the people who work with
the source code must accept
contributions
that is the definition we will be using
when talking about open source here
that's not to say that talking about
licenses about software freedoms about
open source versus free software and the
like are on important topics they are
very important and very interesting if
that's your cup of tea
but for the purposes of this talk it
would only serve to muddy the waters so
for that sake we're making it easier and
using a much simpler definition
i mentioned
that
for something to count as open source
software in our case
it needs to be accessible and it needs
to be
it needs to have a project where a
maintainer is willing to accept
contributions
this is usually done via various
source forges github is probably the
most well-known one but you've also got
things like gitlab like bitbucket like
sourcehut and others
and these are known as sourceforges
these are places where code lives and
where you can interact with both the
code and with people who make the code
they usually have some sort of issue
tracker a ticketing system if you will
where you can report bugs where you can
request features and where you can
interact with the people who make the
software and talk about it
these projects are maintained by people
who are called maintainers
obviously
the other thing about this talk
that we want to talk about is
contributions and contributing
so what is a contribution now that we
know that open source software in our
terms is software that's somewhere
online and that you can contribute to
what is a contribution
the most obvious answer perhaps is code
code itself
it is after all the building block of
software it is code
so it's a simple but very correct answer
code is contribution
however
it is not the only form of contribution
documentation
is another form and documentation is at
least as important as code
the thing about documentation is
it's usually the last thing to get done
because it's
what people really don't want to do
because after you spend days or weeks
trying to come up with this perfect
algorithm and you create the project and
everything lives up here and you know
exactly how it works
you don't really want to sit down and
try and spell it out for someone because
it takes time but it is very necessary
because
the only way you can share this with
other people and make other people
understand it
is by writing it down
so
if you contribute documentation that is
not only helpful to you because you need
to understand enough about the project
to actually
write about it and write about it in a
sensible and coherent fashion
but you also
help the project itself because they now
get more documentation and that helps
newcomers to the project be they end
users or other developers
so documentation is this triple whammy
it's a great place to get started too
because
means you get to learn and you also have
a fresh set of eyes which is really
important
also by contributing documentation you
have to get it run by an expert
the expert in this case being the
maintainer
and
that means they will check your work and
make sure that it's actually correct and
accurate
obviously there are also other forms of
contributions such as marketing
design
and other
whatever you want to however this talk
will focus mainly on code
and on documentation
mostly because
those are the areas where i have
experience
now i mentioned that these forges have
ticketing system
issues issue trackers
does opening an issue
count as a contribution
it's a valid question and it can be hard
to answer
my stance on this is that it depends on
the issue but if it's a well written
issue
then yes it definitely counts as a
contribution
because
it helps the maintainers
to see
what
to find faults with the program to
figure out what doesn't work or what
users want it helps them improve things
by getting real feedback from real users
so assuming
that it's a well-written issue
yes i would say it counts as a
contribution
but do be mindful of about just opening
issues willy-nilly because they do take
time to triage and someone has to look
at them
if they're duplicates of issues that are
already there then just create extra
work which is also not ideal
so with
our definition of open source of
contributions and
having talked about issues
let's get started let's actually look at
four simple steps to get you started
in open source this will be a fairly
high level overview
and i won't dig really deep into any
technical topics
but it's worth catching because it's
four steps that you can always follow
we'll start with number one
identify a problem
if
you're going to contribute something you
need something to contribute to you need
something to fix something to do
and that is the problem
so what is a good problem well that
is up to you
it can be a number of things for
instance
if you want to learn a new language
maybe you find a project that's written
in the language you want to learn you
sit down and you find an issue that
looks
easy enough to solve or maybe you just
want to get started with learning about
a framework
say
take the javascript framework react for
instance if you want to learn how it's
structured how it actually works a great
way to really dig into the code base
is to find an issue
a lot of
projects will have labels for their
issues
to
that are equivalent of good first issue
or the like issues that are intended or
requests or whether maintains requests
someone who's new to the project to get
started these will usually be fairly
simple and the maintainers will also be
happy to help you get along to get
started these issues are labeled as such
to indicate that it's a good place to
get started with a project so this is a
great way to get started
another form
or another way to find the problem is
again documentation
you're learning a new
framework or you're learning you're
working through a new project for
whatever reason and you're following
along to the documentation
and suddenly you get stuck
you get stuck and you spend hours
searching for a solution and trying and
wrecking your head trying to figure out
what's wrong and maybe maybe something's
missing or maybe it's just plain wrong
this is a great time for you to step in
step up and go hey
this is incorrect i want to fix this
in fact
that is how i got my very first
contribution
i was
i'd barely gotten started programming
and i was working on a project and i
wanted to check out a tag with git now
if you don't know what this is doesn't
really matter just
if you're new to kit it's maybe not the
standard way of working but the
documentation said
you can't do that git can't check out
tags
but i was confused
because the documentation said you can't
do it in plain words yet on my machine
it worked perfectly
i checked out a tag and things were all
right
so i thought
this seems strange i'll ask about it and
so i opened an issue and
sure enough the documentation was out of
date this was added at a later time and
a later version of the software
so i ended up writing
a section about it about checking out
tags and that also led me into
reading more about git and
i had to research headless mode or a
headless state because if you check out
a tag you might be left in a headless
state and this is about as scary as it
sounds
and
definitely at least if you're new to git
or version control software like it
you can be really scared of that you're
going to mess something up
but i had to learn what it is and how
you get out of it and write a little
section on that too
really helpful both for me
and for the documentation now
if you ask me today
can i explain to you exactly what it is
and how you get out of it
[Music]
maybe but don't don't really count on it
yeah these things slip but yeah that
happens but on the topic of
documentation
there's a quote by chris coyer a
quite
prominent figure in the front world and
also the editor of css tricks and he
says
write the blog post you wish you'd found
when you searched for it
and for documentation it's the same
thing
if
the documentation that you find isn't
up to par if it isn't what you wish
you'd found if it's got wrong steps or
if it's written in a roundabout way and
it's hard to understand
fix it write what you wish you'd found
go change it and make it better
plus again if you're new to the project
that's a bonus point because in your
eyes you don't have the same frame of
reference
that the maintainers have you don't know
everything about the project in the way
that they do
so you know exactly what it's like to
learn
five minutes ago whereas they can't or
they can't remember what it was like to
learn five years ago or five months or
however long they've been on the project
so that means contributing documentation
as a new
person as a new developer as a new
contributor to the project
super helpful
but
these are a couple ways but my favorite
way of identifying a problem
is
do something that makes life easier for
you
if
you've ever been in a situation where
you think oh i just wish that this
little piece of software did this little
thing different or it could do this
then you know what i'm talking about
solving a problem
that makes life easier for you
has one really important advantage to
just picking an issue at random from an
issue tracker
and that is
it offers intrinsic motivation it means
you want to solve it because you keep
running into it over and over and over
again
most likely or it's something that you
really think is important or that you
are passionate about
and
that's really what you need to get
yourself through
i heard a term recently about the github
graveyard and i'm sure we're all guilty
of this i can't see any of you but i'm
sure all of you would raise your hands
if i were to ask how many of you have
more than five abandoned projects lying
around somewhere i know i've got loads
because you get started and say oh yeah
this is so cool
and you just never have the motivation
to get across
like the 70 mark you don't have what it
takes to get those last percentages done
because once you've done the proof of
concept was like ah this works
you're done you're not there's nothing
motivating you to keep going
but if it's something that will actually
help you out
then you keep pushing then you won't
want it to get done
because it'll make life easier it might
be a small quality of life adjustment
but it's really important
it will take time but it will be so
worth it in the end now
i'm sure most of you are familiar with
harry potter and if you're not it's a
series of books about
a magical world where witches and
wizards
live and magic is real they use ones the
important thing is
it is not the one
it's not the wizard or the witch that
chooses the wand but it's the wand that
chooses the witch or the wizard
and in a similar way
in open source i don't think that it's
the best for the developer to pick an
issue but rather it's the issue that
picks the developer it's the issue that
finds someone who's
caring enough and who's actually annoyed
enough at this issue to fix it
and that is a great way to get started
and this is also
how i came into or how i got my last
contribution or my most significant one
to date
because i was working or i was looking
playing with new shell
which is a new shell as the
name implies
and
it is written in rust which is also
great because sometimes
your other interests coincide with the
issues you find and i've been really
into russ for a long time
and so getting hey it's a shell it's
written rust awesome
it's two things that i love right there
and i was using it with kubernetes
another thing that i think is really
cool
and
what happened was that i got some output
that i was nice and human readable
i thought oh this would be so great and
it looks like a table so new shell
should be able to pass this and create a
really good data structure because
that's what neutral does it gives you a
like table structure for all these
things look it up super cool
but
the problem is the output that i got
from this command
he wasn't in any standard machine
readable format it was very human
readable but not machine readable
so
what do i do
i open an issue say hey here's my use
case i wish this would work it doesn't
can we fix it or is there another way to
get around it
again
i was told oh hmm we should do this this
this sounds like a reasonable thing for
us to do
and so i wrote a parser for
space-separated values like tables
natural tables are just formatted with
spaces
that's great
three things that i love smoosh together
into one
makes for intrinsic motivation makes for
something you want to do
now it turns out in the end that sure i
could have probably just gotten the json
output and piped it through some sort of
parser but where's the fun in that right
okay so assuming you've identified a
problem you know what you want to work
on now you know you've found the project
you found the problem you want to solve
what's the next step
open an issue
or rather talk to the powers that be
talk to the maintainers
you start by navigating to the project
at this point you might want to look in
the project repo
in the root folder there might be
something called a contributing file
usually called contributing in all caps
this file might come if it exists might
contain information on where and how you
open issues you should probably look at
this before you go any further but more
than likely
it's okay to just jump directly to the
issue tracker and look for similar
issues
if you've found an issue then you're
probably not the first one to find it
so
instead of creating more work and
duplicate work for the maintainers
let's try and see if we can find the
issue already has it been opened if you
find an issue that reports the same
thing that you want to say
whether it's the same feature the same
bug the same missing documentation
check it
do the maintainers agree that this
should be fixed is an issue
and if they do is anyone else working on
it here's the thing
in
in open source when it's free for
everyone to work on
you still want some sort of structure
if
someone has already started working on
an issue you don't really want to come
in and just seal it that would be a
breach of etiquette because they they're
already working they've claimed it so to
speak
and i'm sure you can identify with that
if you if you're working on something
and you you really want to do this you
want to show that hey i can do this and
then someone else comes and steals it in
front of your nose that's generally not
a good feeling so see
if anyone has
claimed it if they haven't say i want to
do it
if they have and nothing's happened for
a long time it's okay to poke them and
go hey are you still working on this or
what's the status
so that's one way to get going the other
if the issue doesn't exist already
create a new issue
explain
what your problem is explain
whether it's a feature request whether
it's a bug report or whether it's
documentation or whatever you want to do
explain why and explain how
explain also that you'd be happy to take
this on and do this
but remember
especially if it's a feature it might
not be that it aligns with the project's
goals and
in the end it is the maintainers that
own the project it is the maintainers
that decide whether something gets
merged in or not
as such
it is important to open an issue before
you start working on the problem so that
you don't just show up with a bunch of
code and go hey here's my stuff because
maybe you don't want it
usually though or often depending on
what your feature is
the maintainers might be happy to go
along with it and it's a good thing to
do and you can get started
if you can't
and if they don't want this issue you
can either go back and identify another
problem
or
you could create a fork and do stuff on
your own
but that's not what we're going to talk
about now we're going to assume
that you got the issue that you claimed
what you wanted and i or that you
created a new one and that is yours to
work on
and so that's step two step number three
do the work
just do it it's
that's simple
this you might expect to be the meat of
the talk
but
i can't really say much here because
what you do and how you work on it
really depends on what the issue is
and how you want to fix it this is your
time to shine this is where you step
forward and go okay
i want to fix this and i want to fix
that and so and so
but
remember the contributing file i
mentioned
use that before you start and see if
they have certain guidelines like code
style and like commit style and the like
try and follow this as much as you can
write tests if they require that do
continuous integration and work on
various things
just try and follow this and talk to the
maintainers if something's unclear
and do feel free to ask them questions
while you're working
but aside from that i don't have any
secret tips or tricks for this all you
got to do is just grind through it sit
down do the work
and make it shine
now whether this is fun or not that
depends on you that depends on how you
feel about the issue but more than
likely as a developer
i'd sure hope that you want to do this
because you're doing this
in your spare time presumably and for no
pay so
hopefully you're into it
right so that's three steps done
next
up the last one submit the pull request
so you've toiled away now in the
darkness for what seems like months in
your little cave and your fingernails
are long and the scratching on your
keycaps and your clothes are all tired
and torn
and but you finally found the perfect
solution and so you emerged from uk
victorious
now what
what do you do
see this
is probably the most complicated of the
steps that i've outlined so far
it's an appropriate final boss if you
will but
even if a pull request might be
conceptually
fairly simple but still an intricate
thing to do
luckily it doesn't require intimate
knowledge of git now
i've been talking about git this whole
time and i realize that there are other
version and control systems out there
however in my experience git is usually
what you'll run into so that's that's
that's why i'm talking about that but
there are others i know i know
so
as i mentioned during the last step
about using the contributing file about
making sure that your commits are in
order that things are right
just double check that
and make sure you haven't left any
profanities in the code and comments in
commits or anything because that doesn't
reflect when you don't
some projects might wish you to squash
your commits before you contribute again
this is part of the contributing file
and
if you didn't know squashing commits
means you take a bunch of them and just
squash them down into one giant commit
with all the changes
this can get technical and i'm not going
to really talk about it they're here but
do know it might go wrong last time i
did that i had to
create a new branch and just do
everything all over again
i didn't lose any work i just really
really messed up my current branch
opening a pull request is usually done
through a button in the web ui of one of
your source folders so it's a fairly
simple thing
but
so as long as you've gotten this far and
you've opened the pull request you've
made your changes and it's all here
the next step is to get feedback from
the maintainers
and this
this is scary part this is when you've
got other people looking at your code
and reviewing your code and making sure
that you're good enough
except it's not about whether you're
good enough it's about whether your code
is good enough and
it's scary
there is
the chance a lot of imposter syndrome
going around in open source and in
software in general and you might feel
like i'm not sure it's good enough
but
believe in yourself and trust that yeah
if you made the changes and it works and
you follow the guidelines it's good
enough
and often
you'll get feedback saying hey this is
this looks good
but they'll have a couple of things to
change and this will be about maybe
reusing patterns that are exists
otherwise other other places in the code
base or maybe it is about
uh well this doesn't quite conform to
our code style or so-and-so
so they might have some feedback for you
or maybe they think about this one edge
case that maybe you haven't covered
listen to them
and
just bear in mind that they're not
really critiquing you they're critiquing
your work and it's not to be
it's
and it's only to make the project better
not for any other reason
so assume good faith from the maintainer
and listen but also feel free to discuss
and
stand for your choices and especially if
you thought about it maybe you haven't
just haven't thought about it and that's
okay we'll change it but if you say i
think this is a better way to do it have
a discussion and see what comes with it
assuming
now that you've
gotten some feedback and you've agreed
that yeah okay i'll fix this
you start iterating you go back to doing
some more work get back into your little
cave sit down type a little bit more and
emerge again
this time you can implement the changes
and you do this
until
you've got
all
approvals and it's all good
just as a little side note when you make
the changes you don't create a new pull
request you just update the one you've
currently got
but assuming that you've gone through
this loop back and forth and back and
forth
enough times or
enough times for everyone to be happy
then
yeah the pr looks good and we can land
it as the terminology goes
so congratulations give yourself a
little pat on the back a little scratch
on the chin a little pat on the head
whatever you need
to feel good about yourself
just breathe lower your shoulders
you've cleared the technical part of
this talk congratulations give yourself
self-life don't high-five anyone else
because right now yeah you know
but
and this is important open source
isn't all about tech it isn't all about
the software
because
what's the point of something being open
if you don't have anyone to share it
with
by contributing to open source and by
engaging in discussion around open
source software by
talking and on issues and
engaging with maintainers you become
part of the open source community
and that's really important so let's
talk about the open source community in
fact
let's talk about being a good open
source citizen
because
if you're gonna contribute if you're
gonna be part of this
it's important that you
try your best to be a good citizen
not only for your own sake well i mean
people will like you better and people
will get on with you but for everyone's
sake for creating a better community
so there's a couple points here to list
we'll start
by saying
follow the code of conduct if there is
one
much like the contributing file a lot of
projects will have a file in the root of
the project
named code of conduct
and the amount of projects that have
this file is increasing now if you find
one
read it
and understand it
if you've read one or read two you've
probably got the gist of them because
they're usually spawned off from a
standard template but it's important
that you follow them and that you are
courteous and you're being
kind and a good citizen
and if you've read the code of conduct
also again read the contributing file
make sure that your contributions are in
line with what people expect
further on to this contributing file it
contains information for how you
contribute and the reason for it being
there is that it saves the maintainers
having to tell everyone the same thing
over and over and over and over again
if they can put it write it down once
it's much easier
so now you know
how and where to create issues because
that's in the contributing file and you
know how to
act because that's in a code of conduct
so let's talk about creating good issues
let's talk about what you need to
create
an issue that's helpful and beneficial
to the project
for an issue to be
relevant to the project for it to be
beneficial
it must contain relevant information it
must have what's necessary for people to
see it and go ah we can fix this because
so and so and so and so
as such and to assist in this many
projects have what's called an issue
template and they'll usually have a few
different ones they'll have ones for
features for instance where you can say
what you want and potentially how you
think it should be implemented and any
other ideas you've got
and they can have things for bugs for
instance where you have a short
description and you say i expected this
to happen but this actually happened
and you might also have others for
documentation or other other forms of
issues
use these because they will help you
put down the information that you need
and that the maintainers need
to
look at the issue and to understand what
needs to be done
so absolutely try and avoid and provide
as much relevant information as you can
but at the same time
try and avoid irrelevant information
because if it's just noise it's really
hard to work through and it's hard to
know exactly what you're actually
looking for
so
a good balance here might be to add as
much information as you think
is sensible
if
i would rather err on the side of adding
too much than too little however
it is perfectly fine to say okay
i've added all the information i think
is relevant if you need anything else
let me know i will be happy to provide
it to you remember it's a dialogue it's
going back and forth it's not just a
one-way thing it's not just here's the
issue and that's it usually
you will want to have a dialogue with
maintainers and
talk about
how can we fix things and what's wrong
and answer questions and you know posit
more questions to them
and
when we're on
engaging with maintainers and creating
issues a big no no no don't do this
and
that's don't insult the project
this
this might seem obvious
but
you'd be surprised at the things i've
seen and i've hardly seen any of it
so
do not insult the project it is okay
it is perfectly fine
to be frustrated
to be
confused if you spent an hour or a day
trying to make something work but you
can't
because the documentation just isn't
good enough or something just doesn't
work the way you want it to
it's okay to be frustrated and it's okay
to say i'm i'm frustrated because i've
been trying to do this all day but i
can't make it work
or i'm confused that's fine but don't
say
this is stupid don't
actually insult the budget it's okay to
say things aren't as good as i can be
but
don't
do it in a very negative way don't say
this is stupid this sucks let's throw it
all away this is garbage because people
do that and it's yeah it's not great
but if you don't want to insult it what
you do want to do
is provide compliments
give compliments where applicable
everyone
likes getting compliments everyone likes
having their ego stroked every once in a
while everyone likes
seeing that people enjoy what they
create and what they maintain
so by being by showing appreciation for
the project
you instantly make the maintainers that
much more likely to interact with you in
a positive way
and to want to help you
and it also shows that you genuinely
enjoy or that you are invested in the
project if you can say hey i've been
using this daily for so-and-so and it
saves
saves my bacon every day or
something like that where it's you can
show that you actually use it and you
like it and you care about it and that's
why you're reporting it
it's just that much more useful and that
much more helpful and so much easier
to have a positive
conversation
also
if you see a bunch of pr's that are
stuck that have been
stuck for ages that are just sat there
and nothing's happening either one or
many remember this does happen because
maintainers are busy
contributors are busy
maybe they can't quite agree on what the
way forward is
and maybe they're just
waiting because someone's going through
something right now so they just
they'll fix it but it'll be a week or
two or so
that's okay be
patient
have time things
aren't instantaneous they take time
so
in addition to being patient and being
courteous
in a world where you can be anything
be kind
and
this needs saying more than it should
but it does
remember the human
when you're interacting with someone
they're not just an avatar and some text
on the screen they're not just this
little speech bubble with this little
rectangle with text in it they're real
people
they have real lives and real jobs real
friends and real family just like you
and just like me
remember this and they probably work on
the project in their spare time
they're probably not paid for it
yes there are certain maintainers that
are paid for it and who work on it as a
full-time job
the majority
i think
don't
be aware of this
and
understand that people might have lives
outside so things take time
and also
if
someone comes across as rude
before you take offense which is it's
fine
and it's perfectly acceptable but before
just take a little step back and think
they might just be having a very bad day
maybe something's just gone really
sideways for them that day and
then this thing happens and they or
maybe they want to clear it out and or
just get their mind off it and they
start responding to you
i don't know about you because i can't
see you and i can't hear you but i know
that for me personally if i'm having a
really bad day then sometimes yeah that
does leak out into
interactions with other people who
aren't actually part of what was going
on that day
also
maybe they just didn't think about the
wording maybe they didn't think about
how they put it in
text short and sharp
can come across as very rude and
off-putting
even if it wasn't meant that way maybe
they just want to be brief and say oh
this needs to be done
but it's hard when you don't have body
language we don't have tone of voice to
underline what you're saying
and also
english or whatever language you're
speaking might not be the first language
it might not be the second third or even
their fourth language maybe they don't
speak this language at all
maybe they're using a translator to
interact with you
two days ago jurgen klopswig the
maintainer of segwayo
in his talk an almost free lunch here at
ndc mentioned that he had an issue
opened by a chinese contributor
in chinese
now from what i understand jorgen
doesn't speak chinese he doesn't read
chinese so they used google translate to
communicate with this person in the end
they solved it and was to do with
chinese file names or non-ascii file
names not being treated correctly on
windows
and
that's a great thing to get sorted out
but in this conversation
when you go through a translator
i think we're all aware that it's
probably not the most eloquent chinese
that came out at that end
so
keep that in mind
before responding negatively make sure
they meant it that way
and
try and put yourself in the shoes of the
maintainer or the person on the other
end
again referring back to your organs last
week because he had a really good talk
about just this most of the interactions
i have with users are wonderful he says
and i love the community to death
that's a positive thing that's a
positive thing and i think that's really
important and it's
how we should think about them however
sometimes people are entitled sometimes
people are lazy and honestly
sometimes people just are nasty it's
a shame
but it happens and we must acknowledge
that some people
are just bad actors maybe they don't
have good people skills
there's a lot of this around in tech and
there's stuff like elitism where people
use massive big words to try and
appear really important and show that
they know what they're talking about and
you probably don't
and it's
really
toxic is the word for it
sometimes you need big words absolutely
but you don't always need them and
there's a time and place for it
now remember the code of conduct that i
mentioned earlier
there are communities where
they've actively fought against getting
one in stated where they've said we
don't want one
and
that's just mad because it's there for
us to show respect and to
engage with each other in a productive
manner
some people
really are just bad seeds and
sometimes you can't change it
sometimes
that's just how things are
and you need to
know when to walk away
the easiest way to
deal with a project where you don't feel
welcome or where people are toxic
is you stay away from those projects try
and find
communities
where everyone is welcome
finding welcoming communities in tech
can be hard but it is really really
important
you should find a place where you feel
welcome
and find a community where you feel like
you can contribute and where you can
help
and create
a community that is welcoming not only
to you
but to others
now a large part of this is welcoming
minorities and underrepresented groups
in general
tech and open source as well skews
heavily towards white and cis male
and this is a problem that we must
acknowledge
as dylan beatty pointed out in his
keynote here on wednesday
we need more diverse people we must do
better
greater diversity helps us create better
software and more robust communities
and there's so much discrimination going
on out there right now and
what with if there's anything we've
learned from the past few weeks
and the events over in america
particularly it's that racism is still
alive and it's still well
and it isn't exclusive to the american
justice system it is everywhere
so we must
do what we can to fight against it to
anyone watching to anyone listening who
identifies with an underrepresented
group
know that you are all welcome and you're
all wanted you're all needed we need you
to create a community
that fosters diversity and that is
really the best that it can be
now yes of course
it's easy for me to say i'm privileged
and i'll never really understand but i
want to help and i want to stand with
people i want to stand with you
i don't have the right to speak on
anyone's behalf but what i can do is i
can listen i can encourage other people
to listen
listen
keep listening
and when you think you're done
listen some more
show
support
and amplify their voices
be
be a positive force for good and to open
up and welcome everyone
because representation matters
representation
really makes a difference
and if we don't actively work towards it
we'll never get there
this might not change the world all at
once
but it's a step in the right direction
so
in short for communities for
the actual really important part of open
source
remember be kind be excellent to other
people be what you want other people to
be towards you
be patient and be forgiving
try and understand
but also
know when to walk away
remember the human on the other side of
the screen
remember that they're
people just like you
with troubles and worries just like you
be welcoming
be open
and together let's create a better
community thank you very much that was
the end of my talk i will now go over
into slack see if there are any
questions i'll answer them as we go
along
let's see what i can find
dr
oh
yep
not much happening in webex what's the
youtube link yep uh
that was us at the very beginning of the
talk
now there's no other questions in here
right now if anyone wants to get in
touch with me you can reach me on slack
for the rest of the day and for as long
as this slack team is open if not feel
free to reach out on twitter or any
other platform and i'll try and respond
as timely as possible so thank you very
much for spending this
hour these 15 minutes with me it's been
a pleasure i hope your day is wonderful
and that you enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you very much
good morning everybody and welcome to
the virtual room one at nbc oslo 2020
my name is mark west and i'm going to be
deconstructing deep learning with you
this morning and well at the start of
the afternoon
and um before we begin a little bit
about who i am so
uh i'm a java developer and architect as
you may hear from my accent i'm british
but i've lived in oslo for quite a while
and i work at a consultancy company
called bouve
where i manage a team of data scientists
and data engineers
and in my spare time what's left of it
i'm actually an active member of
javabean the norwegian java user group
so we go around and do all kinds of
things meetups and conferences and
whatnot
but enough of that let's get on with the
talk
so
today as i said before i'm going to be
introducing some concepts behind deep
learning to give you a bit of a kick
start into this very exciting field
my talk is split up into three sections
the first section is going to focus on
deep learning 101 so i'm going to try
and give you some basic
a basic understanding of our how deep
learning works and what it is
then we're going to look at a specific
neural network architecture or deep
learning architecture convolutional
neural networks now these are very good
at dealing with spatial problems and
therefore very good for image processing
and then finally we'll wrap up with by
looking at another type of neural
network architecture recurrent neural
networks and these are very good with
serial data or time series so they're
particularly good at
processing text
so let's get started with the first part
of the talk deep learning 101
and to really understand well the first
thing we need to do actually is actually
define what deep learning is
and deep learning is biologically
inspired machine learning
uh based on multi-layered artificial
neural networks now what does this mean
i've got two pictures here two gifs on
the screen at the moment now the one on
the left is the picture of a brain
rotating around and you can see
activity in the brain now
the theory about how the brain works is
that like the brain is comprised of
billions of cells or neurons
and these are organized into
hierarchical groups and and basically
they're all connected to each other and
when you activate one new neuron it will
send on activation to other neurons and
so on and so forth in a kind of
cascading activation across the brain
and the theory is is that that helps us
well it makes us what we are it gives us
intelligence helps us react to things
gives us the ability to see hear reason
and so on and so forth
artificial neural networks are based on
that theory so artificial networks
neural networks are a set of
computational nodes that perform simple
mathematical functions that are
organized into hierarchies and connected
up to each other and they allow
computers to learn and do things which
you know basically uh seem
intelligent
now neural networks basically
comprise of nodes and connections and in
this picture i'm showing you now this
gif you can see the nodes are the orange
circles and the connections between them
are the black arrows
and this picture here is of a what we
call a multi-layer perceptron
in other words it's a set of
computational nodes organized into three
layers
and as you can see what's happening is
information is coming in to the left of
the network and it's passing through the
network
activating the nodes on the way and then
you get some kind of result at the end
now this is a feed forward architecture
as you can see information is flowing in
one direction it's flowing from my left
to my right
or you're left to your right in fact
and this network is densely connected
in other words it means that each node
is connected to all of the nodes
downstream
this means that when you start dealing
with big neural networks
like you know which are containing maybe
hundreds of thousands of nodes
you would have a large amount of
connections between those nodes and that
can really raise the computational
complexity of your network
another thing i just want to mention
quickly is that the connections in these
types of networks are weighted in other
words the connections can amplify or
dampen specific inputs and i'm going to
explain more about that in just a couple
of slides
networks are generally organized into
layers and there's three basic type of
layers that i want to inform you about
the first type of neural network layer
is the input layer this is where
information comes in to the neural
network now an input layer is basically
the contract this is where we define the
shape of the data that we want to come
allow to come into the neural network
a good example might be if you have a a
picture of 10 by 10 pixels a grade scale
image of 10 by 10 pixels that's one
value per pixel so then you would need
10 by 10 pixels or 10 by 10 nodes in
your input layer to take that
information in in other words you'd need
100 nodes in your input layer
and the input layer doesn't do anything
else it just provides an endpoint for
which your client can call your neural
network
information is then passed on to the
hidden layer now the hidden layer is
where the magic happens what the hidden
layer is going to basically try and do
it's going to try and correlate between
the given input
and the desired output when you're
training the network so if you're
showing the network a picture of a cat
the hidden layer is going to work out
okay what do i need to find in this
picture to say this is a cat so that's
what the hidden layer is doing that's
where the learning is taking place
and a hidden layer is so cool because
it's actually not exposed to the outside
world
after the hidden layer you have the
output layer this is where the output
comes from neural network and this is
going to deliver the end result so the
output layer needs to reflect
your use case so if you just have a
simple true or false
output then it's okay just to have one
node maybe with a value from 0 to one
but if you want to find 10 different
types of animals in pictures you're
going to need 10 nodes in your output
layer each one of those nodes
representing one of the animals you're
trying to find and given the probability
that the animal has been found in the
pitch you've just given it
so deep neural networks are basically
artificial neural networks with more
than one hidden layer that's it
this does not mean that deep neural
networks are more intelligent
it means they're more complex
but it also means that like when you
have multiple hidden layers you can
delegate different jobs to these hidden
layers as we'll see later on
so now we understand the overall
architecture of the of the neural
network but we don't really understand
what's happening with all of these nodes
i mentioned before they're computational
nodes and they're doing simple
mathematical calculations but what does
that actually mean well let's just look
at a artificial neural network node and
try and understand what's going on
the first thing to remember is there's
lots of inputs coming into a node there
could be literally hundreds of thousands
of inputs coming from the previous layer
into a given node especially in a
densely connected neural network
and um all of these inputs that are
coming in will be weighted in other
words they will have weights assigned to
them that will amplify or dampen the
input's strength now this is how a
neural network trains by adjusting these
weights we can actually train a neural
network we can get the neural network
for example to be more focused on the
features that make up a cat than the
features that make up a dog
all of those awaited inputs come into
our note and the first thing that
happens is they're all summed up they're
all added together
and then that sum of weighted inputs we
push through a simple mathematical
function called an activation function
and that activation function will decide
what kind of output the node will give
out now if we look at how the human
brain works uh cells in the brain they
have a threshold and once that threshold
is exceeded they will fire that's the
same kind of thing that an activation
function is doing
and then the output from the node will
be sent to the next layer of the
artificial neural network and
this could this output could be spread
to literally hundreds of thousands of
nodes in the next layer
so that's basically how a neural network
node works it takes the inputs those
inputs are all weighted it takes them
all in adds them together and then
decides what kind of signal will i push
on further in the network by using an
activation function
so a little bit about activation
functions now i try to avoid mathematics
in this talk but like we are kind of
stepping into that territory now when we
talk about activation functions what an
activation function does in simplest
terms it converts an input into an
output via some simple calculations and
there's many different types of
activation functions out there so i'm
not going to go into great detail about
them but i'm going to give you three
examples of activation functions and try
and explain how they differ
so what i've done here is i've drawn a
simple grid on the on on the on the
slide and um basically i'm mapping the
output value or the input value to the
output value and i'm just assuming the
input range is from minus one to one
the first sort of activation function
that we'll look at is a sigmoid
activation function
and what the sigmoid activation function
does it gives a value it gives you an
output between 0 and 1. so this is a
good one if you want to look for
something true or false right and so we
see here is if our input is -1 then we
get 0 out if our input is 0 then we get
0.5 out and if our input is 1 we get 1
out so what we have is we we have a
non-linear relationship between the
input and the output of this activation
function
and this is similar for the next type of
activation function we look at this is a
hyperbolic tangent activation function
and the difference between this and the
sigmoid activation function is that it
has a higher or wider output range it
goes from zero no it goes from sorry
minus one to one
it centers the data on zero
and then we have another type of
activation function this is called the
rectified linear unit and all this one
does is a simple if-then-else statement
it says if the input is less than zero
round it up to zero otherwise just give
out the input that came in as the output
so the rectified linear unit is very
good at just removing noise removing all
minus values from your data
now there's lots of different
activation functions out there the
behavior and the pros and cons is very
based on your use case but i just wanted
to give you an idea of how they look and
how they work
so now we understand what a neural
network looks like it's comprised of
layers nodes we have activation
functions deciding how information is
sent through the network we have weights
but how do we train this how do we train
an artificial neural network what we do
is we give it training data so we in
this example here i'm training a neural
network to tell me if it sees a cow in
the picture and i'm going to show this
neural network lots of pictures of cows
and the neural network while i'm
training is going to make its best guess
it's going to generate predictions which
are numeric values
and as we see in this example i'm
getting a numeric value out which is a
probability score like 0.15 chance that
this is a cow in other words this isn't
a cow so the network isn't doing a very
good job
so we generate these predictions and
then what we do is we compare
the predicted output or the output we
got from the network with what we wanted
to see this is a kind of supervised
learning
so these values are numeric so we can
actually
subtract the predicted value from the
expected value and calculate a loss so a
loss function calculates the difference
between
what the network predicted and what it
was expected to predict and that loss
function the bigger it is the bigger the
error
so then we can use that loss function to
update the weights
the result of the optimization sorry the
loss function will be passed backwards
through the network updating the weights
in a process called backpropagation and
the idea is that we're going to fiddle
with the weights and try and adjust them
so that the next time the network sees
the same picture that we have a lower
loss in other words we have a closer
match between the predicted and the
expected value and that's basically how
we train neural networks it's just like
showing uh pictures to a child and
saying who is this who is this and who
is this and eventually they'll remember
who you're showing them or when you
train kids to to recognize sheep in
picture books for their kids it's a very
similar process
now
how do we update the weights in the
neural network how do we do that how do
we know which way to to to turn them up
or down to get the best results the
answer is we don't
we don't have a map
so it's a kind of a case of trial and
error
how we actually update weights in a
neural network is through a process
called gradient descent
and what i've drawn here is a simple
little graph which shows you different
possible
loss values for different weight values
this is a very it's a gross
oversimplification of what's actually
happening but it's a good visualization
so what happens is when we start
training the network we might be here
where the start flag is so in other
words that we have a certain setting on
our weights but we have a very high loss
and what we want to do is we want to
find our way down to the bottom of this
hill
but we don't have a map
and we're basically blindfolded so you
imagine being on the top of a mountain
you're blindfolding you want to find
your way down the bottom of a hill how
do you do it
you you pull out your foot and you try
and take a step downwards you don't go
upwards but you always try and go
downwards and that's basically the same
as what gradient descent does it make
small adjustments to the weights to try
and take the
the value of the loss down and um the
amount of adjustments to the weight is
called the track the learning rates
so if you want to take small steps you
have a low learning rate or you know a
small learning rate if you want to take
big steps the opposite now if you take
big steps what can go wrong is you can
hop over the global minimum and end up
in the local minimum so this is the
challenge of tuning the learning rate if
you take two small steps it takes
forever to get to the bottom of the hill
but if you take two big steps you might
jump over the bottom of the hill and end
up end up in a local valley which is
okay but not the optimum or not the
lowest place to be
so now we've come to the end of the
first part of the talk
what we've covered is that an artificial
neural network is a set of
interconnected nodes those nodes are
organized into layers the hidden layer
the input layer and the output layer
and deep learning refers to artificial
neural networks with multiple hidden
layers
inputs two nodes are amplified or
dampened by weights and those weights
can be tuned or adjusted using gradient
descent to optimize the artificial
neural network's predictions
okay so now we've done the the machine
learning or should i say deep learning
101 we can now move on to convolutional
neural networks we can actually start
looking at real-life neural networks now
convolutional new networks have really
been a revelation
in that they are very efficient and
they're very powerful and as i mentioned
before at the beginning of the talk
they're spatially os they're
particularly good for dealing with image
processing
and that's what we're going to talk
about here we're going to talk about
using convolutional neural networks for
image processing
but before we go into the detail about
convolutional neural networks i want to
look a little bit at some background
information now first i want to start i
want to start with remember or reminding
you how computers see images
so here we have a picture of an ankle
boot it's a 28 by 28 pixel uh picture of
an ankle boot and it's a gray scale
image says one pixel value per pixel one
value per pixel so in other words i
think 784 individual values in this
image and that's how computers see
images as a grid of pixel values
not as you know the
not as uh the way we do it's basically
looking at this as a set of numbers
and this means that the amount of
numbers
involved in processing images quickly
becomes very very high
so if we have a grayscale image like the
one i just showed you 28 by 28 pixels
it's one channel so one value per pixel
we have 7 784 values but if we have a
color image of the same size 28 by 28
pixels we'd have three pixel values per
pixel we'll have the red the green and
the blue saturation so we end up with
three channels so we end up with 2
352 values
that may not seem like much but we're
dealing with an image that's 28 by 28
pixels when you start getting to big hd
images not your hd images then the
actual complexity the amount of data in
the image is very very high
and this has always been a challenge for
when you're dealing with image
processing using multi-layer perceptrons
or traditional
deeply connected neural networks
and i can show you an example of why
this is a problem
here we see a picture which is like say
say for the sake of argument is 640 by
640 pixels and it's color so it has
three channels
there are
1.2 more than 1.2 million pieces of
information in that picture
so that means that if you send in this
picture as it is into an artificial
neural network you'll need you know one
point well over 1.2 million nodes in the
input layer
now imagine you have a hidden layer
which has around about 1048 nodes to to
that is going to try and work out what
this picture is of
the connections between the input layer
and hidden layer in a densely connected
network
will be nearly 1.3 billion
all of these weighted connections need
to be calculated you know when you send
the image through the network
you will have to create the weighted
values for each one of these connections
you'll have to update these weights
every time you're training the network
you'll have to use the weights also when
you've finished training the network and
you just part when you're actually using
it in prod you'll still be using these
weighty connections so the amount of
processing power required for a 640 by
640 uh
pixel image is relatively high
and that's always been the problem with
modular perceptrons they they require
far too much processing power and also
it takes too long it takes a very very
long time to do this kind of processing
so this is where
convolutional neural networks have
become popular and convolutional neural
networks they um basically
eat the elephant up one bit at a time by
using something called convolutional
filters now these are i've shown you a
couple of uh convolutional filters on
the on the screen now one is a vertical
edge detector and the other one is a
horizontal edge detector they're
basically small grids of values
and what they do is they amplify
specific features in images in other
words if you want to amplify shadows
specific colors lines and so on these
filters will do that
and they're reusable so in other words
these are three by three pixels in other
words nine values you can slide them
backwards and forwards your big
you can slide them backwards and
forwards over your big images
to find or extract the features that are
interesting for your neural network to
see what's more these are weights that
can be learned during uh training so in
other words your neural network learns
which filters it wants to use
by trial and error so it means that like
these filters can actually be reused
later on if you train on your network
your neural network with blank filters
you can actually take the filters that
it learns and use them in the new
network
in a in a
process which is known as transfer
learning
a convolutional neural network will
generally have lots of convolutional
filters each one is going to be looking
for a specific feature in your image
so let's look at an example of how you
can apply convolutional filters or how
they are actually applied in the
convolution on your network we have a
convolutional filter here which has been
trained this is good at finding lines
on the left hand side of an image
it has a size of three by three pixels
it has a stride of one by one in other
words it will move one pixel in each
direction as it slides across the image
here is an original image that we're
gonna look at and this is a very simple
six by six pixel uh image of a black
square
and the result of the of the using the
filter against this image is going to be
a feature map in other words a filtered
version of the image which brings out
specific features that we're looking for
in this case a line on the left hand
side
so the convolutional filter is applied
to the image it starts in the top left
hand corner and what it does is the
values of the filter
are multiplied by the underlying pixel
values and then they're added together
for all of the nine pixels that are
under the filter
and the result is three
the filter then moves one step to the
right
one steps to the right again
and one steps to right again at this
point it's reached the edge of the
picture so this is why this feature map
will be four by four because the the uh
the convolutional filter can only move
four steps in each direction across this
there is ways to actually uh fix that
but we're not going to go into that in
this talk
the filter then moves one level down and
starts doing the same thing again and
once it's finished we end up with a
feature map and this feature map is a
set of numbers which shows us that the
neural network has found something on
the left hand side of the screen
the numbers that are minus on the
right-hand side of the screen
there we can we can see we can look at
them in this particular case as noise
and they will actually be removed so
what we'll do now is we'll apply a
rectified linear unit activation
function to our feature map that we just
generated and the rectified linear unit
activation function if you remember it
takes away all the minus values so we
end up with this new feature map on the
let me see if i can use my yeah on the
right hand side here which is showing a
line here
then we can actually do another step to
further reduce the amount of data going
to the neural network why do we want to
do that well if you remember that
picture i showed you of the budgie
remember the more data that goes into
the neural network the more
processing power it needs so if you can
reduce the dimensionality or reduce the
amount of input going in you can
actually speed up the network the danger
of doing this is that you can actually
reduce the dimensionality so much that
you remove the features that your
network needs to work so this is a bit
of a fine-tuning process but anyway
pooling allows us to reduce the size of
our feature maps even more so we have a
pool here which is two by two pixels has
a stride of two by two which another
words means it will move two pixels in
each direction as it slides across the
image we have our feature map that we
generated in the previous step and we
can apply three different types of pool
to a feature map i just want to show you
how they work
and these pools will generate different
types of feature maps we have max
pooling
average pooling and sun pooling
and when we apply
the pools these pools to our feature map
max pooling will take the maximum number
in the pool
average pooling will add the numbers
together and divide them by the size of
the pool
and some pooling will just add them
together
and we see that the pull moves two steps
across because it has a stride of two
does the same calculation two steps down
two steps across again
so we see how these new feature maps
which are much smaller
still have that information about that
line on the left hand side of the screen
so just to recap
we started with a picture of a square
we applied a convolutional filter to it
which found a line on the left hand side
we removed noise from that feature map
and then we put used pooling to reduce
the size
and what will happen in practice is
you'll have lots of different feature
maps all finding different features
and once those features have been
extracted by the convolutional filters
they can then be passed further onto the
network to the dense layers for matching
against a specific category
so that's how convolutional uh neural
networks eat the elephant one step at a
time they first define all the features
or find the features
and then they send them further in the
network for further processing
so
let's try and look at a convolutional in
your network in context of a real-life
use case
and the use case we can use is the
fashion mnist use case now fashion mnist
is a data set that was created by
zolando
um it contains 70 000 labeled images of
clothing and those images are very very
small and simple they're 28 by 28 pixels
they're all gray scale so one value per
pixel 784 values per image
and um there are 10 classes of clothing
in this data set you have ankle boots
uh i think pullover t-shirt shirt that
kind of thing
and the data is distributed evenly
across these 10 classes so you have 7
000 pictures of shoes seven health seven
thousand pictures of uh sandals and so
on
and what i did uh for the sake of this
talk i trained a very simple
convolutional neural network on this
data set and the the convolutional
neural network can tell us which class a
given image belongs to
and for those of you who like to look at
code you can actually find the code at
my github i'll let i'll share this link
on my twitter afterwards for those of
you who
who want it but if you go to my github
you will find a a notebook which you can
click on and when you click on it it
will open up in google collab google
collab is google's hosted jupyter
notebooks so in other words you can run
my code in in google's hosted notebooks
against their hardware and um yeah
you'll just do everything through the
browser
the neural network i've created is
created using tensorflow and keras it's
actually an old version of tensorflow i
think at the moment it's one point i
can't remember which one but it's a it's
version one of tensorflow so it needs to
be upgraded to version two but still it
still works and you can get a good idea
of how neural networks are put together
and the kind of pre-processing you have
to do
to actually get them to run this code
also includes some good um
code for visualizing what the neural
network's seeing and i'll show you some
examples of that later on
so we can see that this neural network
we have a uh let me see if i can find
there here we go we can this is the
neural network here
so we have one two three four five six
seven layers and we're gonna step
through these layers now and explain
what they're all doing
so here's another view of the neural
network we have our input layer we have
five hidden layers which means it must
be really smart and an output layer
now the input layer is just taking in
our images they're 28 by 28 pixels as i
said before
we've one value per pixel
784 values and um the images are sent
into a convolutional new network in
in the two dimensions or well for a
grayscale image it'd be two dimensions
if it was a color image it would be
three dimensions because you'd have the
three channels so the information comes
into our input layer
and it's then processed by a
convolutional layer and the
convolutional layer will learn
during training or learn a set of
filters and after training it will apply
those filters to the images that will
generate feature maps you know the lines
and the edges and the shadows that we
need for the rest of the network to use
the feature maps will then be pushed
through a max pooling layer the max
pooling layer will reduce the size of
them like i showed you just a moment ago
so these first two layers in the hidden
in the hidden layer or these first two
hidden layers they're all about
extracting the features
right they're all about finding those
lines and extracting them to help the
neural network work out what it's
looking at
the next layer is more of a
you could call it housekeeping layer
it's a drop out layer now the dropout
layer will randomly disable 25 of nodes
in this layer so basically it
mirrors the max polling size and
structure but it randomly deactivates 25
percent of the nodes in each training
run why would i do that well i'm trying
to force my network to learn different
paths to solutions and this is to try
and make the network more generic i'm
actually doing i'm actually trying to
find something called overfitting here
overfitting is when your neural network
just memorizes the training data what we
want it to do is generalize based on the
training data so it can do a bit a
better job with when it actually gets
tested on data it's never seen before
the next layer is another housekeeping
layer this is a transformation layer all
we're doing here is we're flattening our
data from three dimensions to one
dimensions now at this point the data
that comes in here is a set of feature
maps which are by this time i think
they'll be 26 by 26
pixels and there's 32 of them so it's
three dimensions date of data
dense layers don't like three
dimensional data they like it all in one
simple list so the flattened layer will
just convert my three-dimensional data
into a one-dimensional list
and now we're ready to pass our data
into the dense layer and if i remember
correctly this dense layer has 128 nodes
and this layer will decide
what it's looking at this layer will try
and work out am i looking at a square am
i looking at how someone looking at a
car
and in the final layer
we have our 10
notes which are the nodes which tell us
okay what is the network predicting
so
we have actually you know i mentioned
cars and houses and that but this use
case we're looking at here is clothing
right so we have uh one node for sandals
one node for anchor boot one node for
t-shirt and each of those nodes will
predict a probability or give us a
probability of that it's actually found
that
that item in the image
for fun i actually um i after training
my neural network i chopped it up so i
could actually visualize what the
convolutional layer and the max pooling
layer are seeing
and um here we have an example of of off
the network's been trained and i feed in
a handbag a picture of a handbag which
is like from my zolando training set
that comes into my convolutional layer
which is going to apply 32 trained
convolutional filters to the input image
and i end up with these 32 feature maps
and here you actually see what i've been
trying to
get across all this time is that like
the filtered images are like different
versions of the original image that all
bring out different
details i particularly like these two
here because it looks like two pictures
of the handbag from different angles but
it's just basically filters that
highlight different edges
i like this one as well because it just
gives you an outline an overall outline
well this one here gives you more
information on the details of the
handbag
so this is how convolutional your
networks work they filter the image and
they generate different views of the
image which make it easier for the dense
layer to work out what it's looking at
and the max pooling layer
reduces the dimensionality as i've said
before so here is the the set of feature
maps we just generated
and i passed i pushed them through a max
pooling layer with a stride of two with
the aim of reducing the size of the
feature maps via feature pooling and i
end up with this so i still have the
same values or the same images but
they're slightly more pixelated but i've
managed to keep the details that are
important for the neural network to work
out what it's looking at
so
training and testing this neural network
was a relatively simple job i have 70
observations or examples so what i did
is i split my data up with the training
data and testing data
a word of advice you should never
test your network with data it's already
seen you should always test your network
with data it hasn't seen so that's why
you split your data into training data
and test data
and i train my cnn uh updating the
weight survive back propagation every
100 every 256 records i'll do this 10
times so i run through my 60 000
training examples 10 times and this
takes probably about
three or four minutes uh on the google
collab when you run the code on google
colab the code that's available for my
github
and then i test the data with the uh or
test the cnn with test data and score it
based on accuracy how close were we to
what we wanted to see
and here are the results
and we see that we have our different
items of clothing here and we have
different percentages which give us an
idea of how well our neural network
performed with test data
there's a lot of different values here
so i just want to explain what they all
are we can start with precision
precision refers to the amount of
correct class identifications
so in other words is basically for all
of the
how yeah
how
many of the t-shirts i said with
t-shirts are actually t-shirts
so position should be used when the cost
of false positives is high so you can
think about precision is important when
you're dealing with spam
spam emails because if you say oh that's
spam but it's not
then that email is going to get put into
the junk file and no one's going to read
it so that's an example of where
precision is important
then we have recall and recall is the
percent of correctly identified class
members so in other words for all of the
t-shirts in my in my test data set how
many did i actually find
how many did i actually say were
t-shirts
that's recall now recall is important
when the the cost of false negatives is
high and a good example of that which is
quite up to date is covid
if you get tested for covid and you're
told oh no no you don't have it then you
go and you do have it you can go out and
you can spread it around so that's an
example where recall could be important
now a lot of people get confused about
the difference between precision and
recall including me so like a lot of
people just say okay let's just use the
f1 score which is the harmonic mean of
recall and precision
and then you have the overall accuracy
which is the the overall accuracy for
the whole network
here's some examples of incorrectly
classified images and when you're doing
some training it's always good to see uh
or when you're doing testing it's always
good to look at your test data where the
network got it wrong and try and work
out maybe if there's something we can do
with the network to make it better
and there's some good examples here
i particularly like this one here
so the network said this was a t-shirt
and it's actually a shirt now we can see
there's buttons down here so maybe the
network needs to be a bit more better
trained or maybe we need better training
data so the network can distinguish
between t-shirts and short sleeved
shirts
another example here is this one here
it's actually an ankle boot
and there's a pattern here you can see
this little pattern here this was
predicted to be a sandal
and you can understand why that might be
right
and then finally this one down here this
is like something liam gallagher would
wear it's a coat with a hoodie coat and
it was predicted to be a pullover but
it's actually a coat so you can see that
sometimes it's not necessarily the
network's fault sometimes the data
itself
is ambiguous and that's something you
need to be aware of when using neural
networks especially for image processing
so we've come to the end of my session
about
convolutional neural networks we're
going to move on to another type of
neural network in just a second
but to summarize convolutional neural
networks they're spatially aware and
they're good for image processing
they use learnable and reusable
convolutional filters to identify images
in
features in images and what's good with
these convolutional filters if you learn
them for one neural network you can
actually save them and then use them
reuse them in another neural network and
that would be transfer learning
convolutional neural networks require
dense layers to map the features to
classes
and um pooling is an optional step to
reduce the dimensionality of the input
data in other words you reduce the
amount of numbers that are going through
your net neural network and maybe make
it a little bit more efficient but watch
out for things like pooling because they
can actually damage things by removing
the information your neural network
needs to make the correct predictions
and then finally precision recall
everyone's score and accuracy are
different types of metrics for measuring
your modulus performance so make sure
you're using the right metrics to
measure your model's performance based
on your use case
okay now we're on to the final part of
the talk
and we're going to talk about recurrent
neural networks now recurrent neural
networks are a different type of neural
network architecture
which have a specific goal
they deal with problems like this one
here
which way is the arrow moving well here
we have a video
or a gif and a gif is basically a set of
still images played in sequence so you
need to really understand what's
happening or not you don't just need to
understand
the the image itself but you understand
have to understand the sequence of
images and how they relate to each other
to see that the arrow is moving from
one side of the screen to the other
another example of a sequential problem
is understanding text
because
generally when you're reading text you
need the context that comes from the
words before to understand the specific
word and um the overall context requires
an overall understanding of the entire
text as when i was at university i
remember a lot of times i was i was
always reminded by my tutors to read the
whole question before answering and
that's a good example of of you know why
you need to understand the sequence the
words the sequence of the words come in
but traditional neural networks don't
deal too well with this
uh they don't deal well with with
sequential data because they experience
everything at once
and therefore
they're not very good at handling time
series type problems
so this is where recurrent neural
networks come in now recurrent neural
networks are a family of neural networks
with many different types of
implementation but general recurrent
neural networks are based on a having a
persistence layer or persistence in the
hidden layer so basically it's like a
loop in the hidden layer which is
maintaining the state of the hidden
layer between sequential inputs
so what happens with every current
neural network is it you will feed it a
time series
it will take the first sequence in the
time series and feed it through the
network to the hidden layer
the hidden layer will maintain state
between each time series iteration
coming through and then finally when
everything is done the output layer will
give a final result
you can also look at a recurrent neural
network like this basically like it's a
set of identical neural networks that
are sharing the same weights sharing the
same hidden states and they're being
executed one by one in the order of the
the sequential data
problem with recurrent neural networks
is they are pretty much like me they
have a short term memory problem they
forget things very very quickly and
especially if you have a long sequence
in your time series things that happened
at the beginning of your time series can
be forgotten or neglected
in the networks processing so we need to
use a different type of recurrent neural
network a bit of an upgrade to a
recurrent neural network for this for
this
problem we're going to address today and
that is a long short-term memory network
so what these do they introduce
long-term memory
as well as having working memory so they
just add long-term memory to the
recurrent neural network so this means
that like effectively you have two
parallel
conveyor belts going through your
network iterations
and like some information is on the
long-term memory uh conveyor belt and
some information is on the short-term
memory conveyor belt and we have little
workers between those conveyor belts
that move information between these two
as needed
so how is that done well that's done
using gates
so if you zoom in to a long term long
short-term memory uh neural network
hidden node you'll see something like
this so you have your two conveyor belts
going through the long term memory and
the working memory and then you have
these gates which are basically stacked
activation functions that move
information between the long term and
the working memory so you have the
forget gate which will actually remove
stuff from the long-term memory if it's
no longer important to re you know to
have that information
uh input gate will move stuff in the
working memory to the long-term memory
and then finally output gate will
combine the contents of the long-term
memory and the working memory into some
kind of output
so the use case we're going to look at
today is the internet movie database
review use case this is quite a
well-known one and it actually comes
with keras you you can actually
download this uh this data set directly
from keros
and um it consists of 50 000
reviews imdb reviews which have been
manually classified as positive or
negative
and these reviews are encoded as a
sequence of integers so what does that
mean well
neural networks don't care about words
they only care about numbers so what
we've done or what keras have done when
they pre-processed this data set they've
replaced all of the words with numbers
so as a dictionary so you can say that
like
word number 53 maybe refers to the word
but you know and so on and so forth
the thing is with these numbers is the
integer represents that word's overall
frequency in a data set so the word that
has the integer of one will be the most
popular word in the data set so
basically all the words in the data set
have been changed to numbers
and the goal is is going to be to create
a lstm long short term memory
deep neural network that can correctly
classify a movie review
and here we actually see an example of
what the data actually looks like so on
the left hand side you'll see the
encoded data that's what the data set
looks like a list of numbers but luckily
the data set also comes with a codex so
you can decode
the reviews to their original form but
what you'll see is when you do that is
that all punctuation or most punctuation
has been removed
capitalization has been removed you know
it looks like a donald trump tweet
what we can also see here is the most
popular hot word in the whole data set
is the start tag
that has the value of one
and the start tag is just telling us
that the review is starting here
now i'm going to do some additional
pre-processing of this data set to work
with it the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to reduce the size of the
data set or the vocabulary of the data
set because there are 26 i think 26 000
different or unique words in the data
set so i'm actually going to reduce that
down to the most popular 10 000 words so
all words that have a value of over 10
000 are just removed the reason to do
that is i just want to reduce the size
of my training data and try and make my
network more efficient
another thing i need to do is all these
reviews are different lengths
and as i mentioned before the input
layer has a contract right it wants to
see a certain shape of input so what i'm
going to do is all of the reviews that
are less than 500 words long i will pad
them out like i did in this example here
the reviews are more than 500 words long
i'll just truncate every word after the
number 500.
another thing my neural network is going
to use which is important for you to
know about is word embedding now what
word embedding does is it plots words in
a multi-dimensional space that sounds
really kind of like you know science
sci-fi but basically what it's doing is
it's plotting words in a way that we can
see the dimension the different
linguistic relationships between words
uh this picture here which is on the
left-hand side of the screen really kind
of shows what i'm trying to say here i
stole this picture from a guy called
shane lynn who has a really good blog
about uh wedding bedding if you want to
check it out now the words in this image
that are closer together they share
available
we only have two dimensions here now
mostly uh word embedding uh uses a lot
more dimensions you know it may be
hundreds of dimensions
each dimension captures a specific
linguistic relationships between words
the closer they are together in a given
dimension the stronger that relationship
is
and there's lots of pre-trained models
out there but i'm not going to use those
i'm going to train my own because i'm
stubborn so
here is uh the link to my lstm
implementation again it's on github
again if you click on the actual link
not this link here but if you open up
this link and then click on the link
that it contains you'll get
a lstm implementation written in google
colab which will open in your browser
you can run it you can play around with
the code you can test it out you can do
whatever you want to
um once again this is written in
tensorflow and keras and this is a
somewhat simpler neural network we see
here that like it only has six layers
and two of those are drop out layers so
they're just for housekeeping
now if we zoom in on the neural network
architecture a little bit more we'll see
that like yeah we have four hidden
layers and then put an output layer
let's just skip through these very
quickly and explain what they're all
doing
the input layer takes our reviews now
our reviews have been
you know they've had a bit of
pre-processing done to them so they're
500 numbers each and um each one of
those words or which one of those
numbers is representing a word in the
review so the input layer takes in those
500 words and feeds it on to the
embedding layer
now the embedding layer is going to
learn 32 dimensions of word embedding
for each word in my data set so this is
going to create a lookup table
for each word with 32 dimensions of
values and those
word embeddings are going to show how
different words have a semantic similar
similarity to each other so the
embedding layer is capturing word
meaning
we have a drop out layer which randomly
deactivates 25 of the nodes during
training to fight overfitting
exactly the same as what i did with the
convolution convolutional neural network
and then we have our lstm network or stm
layer sorry our lstm layer has 32 notes
just 32 nodes and the lstm layer takes
in
both the review but also the wording
bedding for each word in the review
and what the ls10 will do is it will
learn to differentiate between positive
and negative reviews by looking both
at the word meaning the individual word
meaning but also the context that they
are in together
another dropout layer to deactivate or
to remove overfitting and force our
network to learn different paths to its
goal
and then finally a dense layer and this
final dense layer has one note and that
has a single node with a sigmoid
activation function which will give us a
value and output value between zero and
one
based on zero being closer to negative
and one being more closer to positive
so zoom into these two of these layers
let's have a look at what's happening in
the embedding layer
so the embedding layer as i mentioned
before is learning 32 dimensions of word
embedding for each of those 10 000 words
in my training set and the result is a
lookup table that looks pretty much like
this so you have all of the words that
are represented by integers and then you
have 32 dimensions of semantic
similarity or semantic meaning and those
dimensions are all updated via back
propagation while the network is trained
their weights
okay so this is how the neural network
learns so what this means is a neural
network is never really going to
understand the meaning of these
individual words but it's going to
optimize these values to try and ensure
the network gives the best possible
results
the lstm layer takes that word embedding
and looks at the word order
combines those together and then works
out the difference between positive and
negative reviews
training and testing lstm i took my data
set it's split into training daily and
test data so i trained my stm with the
training data updating the weights of
our back prop every 256 records
i did this three times so three epochs
and then finally i tested my lstm with
the test data which is another 25 000
records with an equal split between
positive and negative and i i generate
my score
and based on the network that i i've
shown you just showing you i got a score
of overall of around about 87 accuracy
so if you remember
precision is the percent of correct
class identifications
recall is the percent of correctly
identified class members
and the f1 score is a harmonic mean
between recall and precision and if
you're still confused about the
difference between recall and position
there are plenty of really good blogs
out there which might help you
and the overall score accuracy 87
so i'm pretty happy with that
but we should always look at some of the
uh the
test data that gave us incorrect results
because that's quite interesting to do
and here is an example of an incorrectly
classified review
and this was predicted to be negative
but it's actually positive
and
there's a lot of reasons why this might
be predicted to be positive or negative
sorry for a start there's a lot of
negative language here
you know the person was disappointed
that the show was cancelled uh but like
um
you see that there is a lot of negative
language there which could drag this
review towards being negative
another thing is there's a lot of these
tags these tags are actually created
when the data set was converted from you
know normal words to integers so these
tags also if they start kind of trending
towards being negative then that's going
to affect the neural network's
performance so maybe these tags should
have been removed
and also we have some leftover html tags
these definitely should be removed right
so we see here that we have a bit of
work to do with the pre-processing our
data and if we use different strategies
for pre-processing our data and
selecting which words to include in the
training and which words to remove from
the training we might get better results
so to summarize
rnns handle sequential data by
persisting state using a working memory
but that work in memory
means that it has like a short term
memory problem
so it's often better to use an lstm
which is a version or a variant of an
rnn which has a long-term memory and
resolves that short-term memory problem
wedding bedding is a very useful
technique for modelling semantic
relationships between words by plotting
them in a dimensional space
and pre-processing of nlp data is always
vital for getting good results
this slide here um contains links to a
few blogs i've written about this um
if you didn't understand any of the
points i was trying to get across you
might be able to
get good answers from the blog entries
definitely go and have a look at the two
technical implementations because
there you'll really get an idea of how
this stuff works and i promise you it
isn't as complicated as it may sound
another thing to remember is that like
i'm not a python coder first and
foremost so if my python code makes you
cry i do apologize other than that i
will be publishing the slides and
everything on twitter later on today if
you do have any questions for me ask
them on the
on the ndc slack and i will answer them
later on this afternoon when they get
home
otherwise i'd like to wish you a
fantastic afternoon and thank you very
much for listening bye
hello and welcome to this talk on
continuous delivery with azure web apps
my name is vidal constalli i work at
bravid based in oslo
norway we're going to investigate a lot
of the functionality that we have
available to us
in azure web apps
for deployment of software
deployment of our application
and that is a very important part of
continuous delivery so we're going to
focus on that
but before we get into the technical
details
i would like to point out a couple of
things
regarding the
heritage of continuous delivery
to me
this book lean software development
has a lot of foundation for continuous
delivery
it's a very good book from
mary and
tom poppendik
it was released in 2003 i think
and it has a lot of good information
that we can
look at
but there are two basic um
basic points that will i would like to
emphasize
first
the notion of delivering software as
fast as possible and the other one is
build integrity in to our process
these two are some of the to my mind one
of the main topics that we need to keep
in mind for continuous delivery
another book that i would like to point
to is the continuous delivery book by
jess humble and dave farley
which was released i think it was in
they um
give us uh principles
for software delivery that we are going
to have a look at
so first they say that you should create
a repeatable reliable process for for
releasing your software
you should automate almost everything
you should keep everything in version
control
if it hurts do it more frequently and
bring the pain forward
again build integrity in
done means released we are considering
ourselves with everything until our
application is in production
and everybody is responsible for the
delivery process meaning that the entire
process should be available
to all people in the team
and of course you should do continuous
improvements of your deployment system
so
when i started my career as a lotus
notes development in the late 90s
we had a system where you could deploy
your application
in a quick
reliable and repeatable manner
it was all built into the system
and you can create your process around
it
moving ahead
20 years we have asher
we have a smurgosport a buffet of
different options to choose from
and the problem becomes what to choose
how do we set up our continuous delivery
system
and
my suggestion is that we should go back
to the theory
in order to guide us on what to choose
because there are so many options it can
be overwhelming
so
what options have we for deploying our
software to azure web apps
the first option you're probably
familiar with
deploying directly from visual studio
it's easily available to everyone
or you could create up create your
entire build system
infrastructure using build servers for
instance in azure devops pipelines or
all or other third-party solutions such
as team city octopus deploy jenkins and
so on
but there are more options
one option which i call version control
deployment
is something that we should we will look
into
and also i will have a look at how we
can use the docker tool and the docker
tool chain to do our deployments
using containers
so let's start with visual studio
deployment
this is typically a
build and deployment pipeline for that
option
in your local development environment
you code your application you compile it
you might run some tests
you build the package and you publish it
directly to the
to the web app to the azure web app
in the scenario of a build
infrastructure
you still have your
development your coding
and you check in your
code to the local repository and then
you push it
to uh to some git repository uh remote
then on azure devops pipelines you check
it out it is compiled you run the tests
you build your packages and you publish
it to a web application
so for the third option version control
deployment you still do your coding and
your check it in to your local git
on your local environment
but then you push it directly to the web
app and you have it checked out you have
it built
running tests build the package publish
it and run it
on the azure web apps infrastructure
so in this case we don't need any
external
infrastructure set up for our build and
deployment pipeline
so to do this we use
a system called kudu
it is not this kudu but this one
in the azure web portal you find it
under advanced tools
there's also a different
a separate portal that is automatically
provisioned
that you can
where you can access it
and there are a couple of things there
that i uh in this tool that i would like
to point out
first on the left we have
a few endpoints that we can use
to connect to it using a computer there
is a git service there is ms deploy
there is an ftp service where you can
push your application and there is a
custom rest based api
also
for the developer
here having a silly
glasses
uh you have this scm portal
the site configuration portal
or or site control management portal i
should say
and of course you have your normal web
front end
where your user can access your
application
here your users
users have a
top hat on for some reason
so
what we can do then is that we can on
our local system you are coding
check it into git and then push it
directly to the to the infrastructure
and have it built there
so going back to this uh slide there are
two
areas or two paths on the local file
system that i would like to point out
one is the repository
here is where your source code is pushed
and there is the www folder where iis
will serve your application
so
the source code is built and then pushed
to www root in order to deploy the
application
so lets have a demonstration
so here i have a very simple.net
application
it could be
other languages but i choose.net
so
uh this is uh just a demo application
dot net run
this is as you might
see from the naming jokes as a service
or jazz as i would like to call it
so let's
let's try and issue some requests to it
so here we have just a simple
root endpoint where i get some metadata
about the other endpoints i could go to
slash jokes or slash science jokes or
chuck norris for chuck norris jokes
and also there's a health endpoint
so let's have a joke
okay
i can issue a new request and i get a
different joke each time
so this is my
important application i would also like
to point out the health endpoint
it is healthy
so what i can do here
i have also provisioned a
web application
called ndc oslo 2020 jokes one
um
in azure it is empty for the time being
so let's try to push up uh push the
application to it
so the first thing i need to do is try
to enable git push to it
uh azure web
app app
deployment source
config
local git
i need to the name of the application
ndc osmo 2020
jokes one and the resource group is ndc
oslo
2020 rg
so what i will get back here is the git
endpoint that i can push to
um
but i also i need to have some some kind
of credentials
in order to push to it
azure
deployment
oh sorry azure web app
list publishing
profiles
so now i get a json array
with
some usernames and passwords that i can
use when i push
to this
so here's a username and a password
i will use this to construct the url
and all the security people look away
this is not how i would like to do it in
production but for the demo purposes
i have
i have a short
script here
that will construct the url for it
and then i will register it as
a remote for git
so here i take the url
git
remote add
jokes
git
push
jokes
so here
you might see that it will actually
generate a deployment script and
run a build and deploy for my
application so it kicks off
dotnet publish basically
once that has been done it will be
copied to the w root folder as i talked
about earlier
let's see when it finishes up
it is copying the file and if we move
back here
we shall see that
my deployment my application is now
deployed let's have a
science joke this time
okay good
so the next step that we can do now
instead of having it
automatically generating a build script
we can try and create our own script
so
let's create a partial script
sorry not there
deploy ps1
no sorry
so
here i basically have a deployment
script that is
similar to the
the one that is actually running
or being generated automatically it
basically does a dotnet publish and then
it uses two uses a tool called cuda sync
to synchronize the compiled files
to www
so but what we can do now is we can add
some more steps to our build so for
instance let's run our tests
so dotnet tests
i need a
parameter parameter for that where i
tell it where the test project is
so and i can try and test my
test my script here locally
deploy sorry
just tell it where to place the files
it will now
basically
run the tests
and then publish the application
oh
let's see what did i do
i should probably run the test before
and i should not run this
synchronization command because this
tool is not available so i have a
separate switch for that
no sync
so now i've added one of the quality
assurance steps to my build pipeline
which is running the tests
and
before we do anything else
there is also another functionality that
i would like to point out that's
available to us
in in azure web apps and that's
something called run from package
instead of having the
application files copied one by one into
www we are creating a sip archive of our
entire application and then we have the
infrastructure mount that into the a
virtual directory on the file system
which is a more reliable and a quicker
way to deploy our application
so if i add
a couple of more steps after the publish
application
i create a zip file from it
and then i create a separate file called
package name txt
which tells the infrastructure which zip
file to deploy
so let's try to run that locally first
apply
temp build tmp and
deployment directory publish
so what we have then
oh
what was that all about let's see here
i didn't save my file
so
in the publish directory we have one zip
file which is our application
and
this package mtxt which only contains
the file name of the file to deploy
so before we push this to the to web
apps we need to tell it to use this
deployment
method
so azure web app
config
apps settings set
settings a lot of settings
there's a special environment variable
that we need to use
web
site run
from
package
and we set that to one
okay then we can add
and check it in
so let's try to push it
so this time
so
project type run from sip so what did i
do what did i do wrong here
project type run from sip let's go and
have a look at the portal
so here's a run from package
should be okay
so it's what does it say preparing
deployment skipping build project type
run from sip
so
yeah of course there is one uh
one thing missing
we didn't tell the web apps
infrastructure about our
deploy.ps1 file
good so
that's very important so let's do that
what we need to do then is create a
special file called deployment dot
deployment
and
this one should just have one
one entry which is the command to run
the build from
and here we are saying that it should
run powershell and execute powershell
and run this
file here
so let's check that in
let's push them to push some jokes
all right so let's see
so now it says running a custom build
command so now it has started to execute
our file
so there are a number of ways we can do
this
the first thing it will do it will look
for an environment variable
on the infrastructure called deployment
if it doesn't find that it will look
inside the repository root for a dot
deployment file
and if it doesn't find any of those it
will try to figure out
how to build
the application basically so that was
the first
approach that we have
that we had
so
good if we now
go back here we can have a look at this
kudu services portal that i talked about
or the scm
so let's have a go and have a look at
the file system
first we can go into the
slash data
site packages and here is our built
zip file with our application and the
package name txt
references which zip file should be
mounted
so if you go to the site wrote
and if we try to edit one of the
files here we will get an error message
saying that this is not
allowed so as a consequence of this
approach
the
web route
is read only so nothing can write to it
because it's just virtually mounted from
the zip file
so
another step that we can do or
that we can add to our system or
deployment system is to use deployment
slots
deployment slots are virtual
sites that you can use to push
your applications before
putting them into production
so we have
basically the same
git possibilities available to us
like we have on the main site
so if i run azure
the
web
app deployment
config
source
if i can spell
config
local
kit and this in this
instance i give it uh the name of a
deployment slot that i have already
provisioned
slot pre
i call it pre before because it's kind
of pre-production
and as you can see now it has a similar
jokes uh
git endpoint that we can push to
and likewise we have the same
publishing profiles with the same
or rather other usernames and passwords
so i can
create a remote for the
pre
uh deployment slot
so we can register that as another
remote
repository and get
git remote add
pre
and we can also push to that
so
basically what we can do now
is that we can push the application have
it built on the deployment slot
and then we can if we want test that it
works the infrastructure will actually
test that the application starts and
then we can switch it automatically into
production to avoid downtime
so
while this one is building
let's go back to the slides i think
so to summarize what we have seen so far
we are pushing directly to the
infrastructure
we have created a locally runnable build
script which means that we can debug it
and run it locally and see that it works
we have added
automated testing to our pipeline we use
the run from package feature
which
allows to
to have a more reliable and quicker
deployment
and this is approach
good for early deployment and for
a small team maybe one or two developers
so
you can extend this of course by using a
remote repository like
github or
azure devops repositories so in that
case you will develop locally on your
system you will push it to github for
instance
then you might add
quality assurance steps like pull
requests and pull request reviews
and then you can have github
trigger
the web application to pull the latest
and build it on the build system
so in this way you can you can add on
branching strategies you can do
different quality assurance like peer
reviews
stuff like that and you can also
the deploy to different
uh environments for instance for
different application branches in in the
version control system so this is also a
fairly good solution for small teams
which again does not need an external
infrastructure for building
or building deployment
so
there are some possible enhancements
that you can do i just showed showed you
the basic steps
for instance you can have your
build system
of preference cake sake whatever
[Music]
you can add your automated
site verification steps
to it
and of course you can push to slack or
teams
whenever a deployment has been done
but of course some of the shortcomings
here is that this this is not very
visible the history of the deployments
to a certain web application is
it's available but it's not really
easily available
and having reports is somewhat difficult
so
let's
have a look at the second option
using devops pipelines
so just to finish this uh
last demo first
we have now deployed to our deployment
slot we can then uh swap
between production and uh
and the pre-production deployment slots
uh azure web app
deployment slot swap
slot pre and here i have to give it the
name
of the web application on slow 2020
jokes one
and
the resource group
so
so now
it will first check that the application
is running in the deployment slot
if it is running then it will shut it
down and it will apply the production
properties to the pre-deployment slot
and then it will fire up the application
and again it will check that it runs and
then it will switch traffic
to it
once the traffic has been switched
the old slot will then be applied
have the pre configuration applied and
then it will be spun up again
so it's kind of it takes a few seconds
to
to perform the application but okay
let's have our next demo
azure pipelines
so let's see here
let's create a yaml file with the
pipeline
oh
so
here i have scaffolded a basic
pipeline
uh there's a trigger which says that it
should automatically trigger when you
deploy to the
ndc oslo 2020 branch
it will run on ubuntu
my first step is just to have
the build number uh written to a version
txt file
so that the application can
serve its version number
then we run the unit tests
basically a.net cli test command
then we publish the test results to the
devops portal so that we can go through
it
then we publish the application
we sip it like we did on our bill in our
build system and then we publish it to
the artifact repository
so but first
let's try and improve this let's
first let's try to reuse the script that
we already have
so the steps to publish
and the steps to run the unit tests
let's instead
run the script that we have sorry
and pipes
so so instead we are running powershell
deploy.ps1
and also let's add on the deployment
part directly so instead of publishing
to the artifact repository let's just
push it directly to to azure
so here we can do a webup deploy
we give it the azure subscription
the application type the application
name
we use the deployment method from
package like before
and now actually let's in the interest
of time let's
go straight ahead and deploy to our
deployment slot instead
pipes
so here what we added
deployment to the slot name pre and then
we issue a command to switch
switch it into production afterwards
so um
we have a new file
and
so uh and this time let's
get let's push it to the origin which is
on
oh sorry
origin
we need to use the correct branch
so
let's have a head over to the azure
devops portal let's create a pipeline
my code is on github
it's this one over here
use an existing pipelines file let's
have a look on the ntc oslo 2020 branch
and there it is
and i just go ahead and kick it off
takes a few seconds to provision a build
server
so now it's checking out the code
it's set the version number and now it's
it's running our
custom build script
good
so
while we wait
um
now let's see
okay it's running the tests
we publish the test results
so it picked up our test results
it's deploying to azure
it's setting this website run from
package to one
before it pushes the patch package
and now it's finished deploying to the
pre-deployment slot so it now it's
it's
it's doing the swap
so
slots are warmed up now it will try to
reapply
the configuration
and start up the application again
before doing the switch
so this might take a few seconds so
while we wait
let's
just have a summary what we have
done so far so now we have offloaded the
build and deployment to our dedicated
environment
we can have our build policies
set up
we can have
more advanced pipelines there are a lot
of tasks available on azure devops
out of the box and also through the
marketplace that we can add on to our
pipeline
but again there are more moving parts
that we take need to take care of and
need to maintain
and we kind of lose the possibility to
test our pipeline locally only the
reusable test script that we created
is really something that we can test
locally so that means that our feedback
cycle is is quite much longer when we do
a change we watch the results it takes a
few minutes typically
[Music]
so let's see what we are how we are
doing so now here the
swap seems to be finished
so if i move to my second
jokes server
we should see some get some jokes there
as well good
excellent
so
the next demo that we can have or change
that we can do is to
use the docker to
tool chain to build our application
and also to deploy our application
so that means that the compile run test
build package part is inside a docker
a docker file
we will publish uh the resulting
container image to
the docker hub or rather i have set up
an azure
container registry for this purpose and
then
it is pulled
from there to the web application so
let's have a look at that as well
so
first let's create a docker file
so here we have a multi-stage
docker
build
so we use two images uh
for this
one is called
slim
or 3.1 buster slim asp.net 3.1 buster
which is only the runtime environment
and one called justbuster which is
contains the sdk that we can use to
build the application
so the first step is the build step
where we actually
restore
we run the.net tests
and we publish the test results
so here we have i've done some command
line tricks
in order
to get the test results out so here
if the net tests failed meaning that it
will
any tests failed
it will actually create a test
failure file
and this file we will pick up in the
publish part and stop the publish if
there is a test failure
so here
in the publish step
we test is there a test failure file
then we just exit
with a non-zero error code
otherwise we will publish
the web application
and basically we create the final
distribution image by copying only the
compiled files
to it
i would also like to add on a health
check
which
basically checks that dash
health is available so that it
the application we can detect early if
the application doesn't boot
so
docker
build
let's tag it with
jokes
latest
here i have already my the the base
image is pulled so it's quite
quick
the restoring of the
for the net application however is takes
some time often
now it's running the tests
[Music]
good let's try and test
the container
or the image let's see docker
run
access it to port 80
touch
jokes
latest
so let's see if we can issue a few
commands
okay so it seems to be up and running
let's have a science joke this time
good
so now we have
our
docker
build pipeline set up the next thing we
need to do
is to create
a separate
azure pipeline for it
azure
pipelines.docker.yaml
so
again let's have a quick walk through
we have a trigger like before
we run on ubuntu
we create a version txt with the build
number
then we kick off the docker build
basically the same command like i just
tested locally
and then we have a separate step
to fire up a container from the image
which is labeled test equals true
and here we copy the test run results
um
and then again then we remove the
container
before
going on to publishing these test
results to the azure devops so this is
kind of a way to extract the test
results from
from the image
so the next thing we log into the azure
container registry
we push the
the container image there
and then we tell the web application
that it should run this container
or should should use this image to
create a container from it
so here we use the azure cli
um
to set docker custom image name
and again we do this on our deployment
slot
and then we swap it into production and
this time i used azure cli also to do
the swap
swap operation
so again let's check this in
let's see do we have everything we have
a new docker file and we have the azure
pipelines for the docker
oh let's do one more thing
let's just go and we don't need the old
uh pipeline to trigger anymore so just
let's just change
let's change this
so
it is pushed then we move over to the
pipelines
azure
sure develops pipelines and we create a
new pipeline
so
sorry
new pipeline
again
github
existing
pipelines file let's look at the ndc
author 2020 branch
this time let's have the docker one
and kick off a build
okay so now it's kicked off the docker
build it has pulled the images
it's starting running the script
uh
okay so it's running the tests
tests are good
and publish the application or sorry
publish the image to
repository
push the image
and we tell the web application which
container or which image it should
use
so of course
here
in this case i have um
i have a provisioned a web application
which runs on a linux application plan
that's basically
it
it also has set a few configuration
parameters
because i'm not using the docker hub but
rather i use azure container registry i
need to have the url to the server
and that's a username and password that
the application can use to connect to it
yeah
so let's see how are we doing so it has
deployed
the container uh it's now doing this
swap
so let's see if we can issue a command
or issue a request to it
so
the host is this is jokes number five
let's see
oh yeah there it is ready serving jokes
let's have a chuck norris joke good
there we go there we go
so also i would like to
point out that we now here in the portal
can go and look at our test results
basically we have everything available
to us here also in the case where
any tests fail we can go here into the
portal and and see which tests failed
and so on
good so just a summary
to summarize
we have now used the docker tool tool
chain
which you might which might be your
preference
you can easily develop you can run and
debug bug
everything locally
and
everything like the runtime in tools
included in the container image so that
you are basically free to
pretty much include anything that can
run on linux and can talk http to run
your service
you get a somewhat the cheaper hosting
if you move to linux versus windows
and
further down the line if you want to
change hosting provider you have
an image technology that can run on all
large providers
so just to have a brief talk about the
key features of the azure web apps that
do a web application
service that we have talked about we
have seen how we can
run our build
on the azure app service
itself
we have seen how we can use deployment
slots to deploy
with zero downtime
you can also do an automatic swap
on windows infrastructure if you want to
because
in in rx in my examples i explicitly
issued a swap command but you can have
the infrastructure set up to do that
automatically once a deployment is done
in a certain slot
and it detects that the application is
healthy it can swap automatically into
production
we have also looked at the opportunity
to run containers
on
azure web apps
i didn't say much about that uh in the
beginning
but i've have er
i have provisioned all the
infrastructure using arm templates
i would urge you to do either that using
arm templates or the azure cli
any form of scripting instead of manual
provisioning is
is good
so
again we started out to look at the
different options that we have for
deployment to azure web apps and i said
that
we use try to use the principles of
software of continuous delivery to guide
us on how to to
on how to choose
how to do it
my message would be that you should
choose the deployment approach to
based on your current needs and also be
open to switch approach during the
lifetime of your application
[Music]
but have your build and deployment
scripts checked into vcs
have it in the proximity with your code
so
that it is available to developers
in an easy manner
uh
and also you can reuse it if
if you
switch your
your deployment approach
so here are just a small summary
pushing from local git is a good way to
get started
maybe for
development small development small
scale development single developer maybe
two or so as a proof of concept during
prototyping it's it's a good approach
you can add on to do the deployment via
github for instance or
or services like that for small teams
you can have multiple environments
you can do branching
creating your
logic and your process around that pull
request and so on
the azure devops pipelines is of course
a more full-blown
dedicated infrastructure for
good for complex
solutions
more advanced workflows versioning
reporting
and so on and also as a variant of that
you can combine that with the docker
tool chain
where you are kind of more cloud
independence
independent
you can also have versioning reporting
and so on so it's more of a
what you prefer uh in terms of your
your
ci cd
so that's it my final message would be
to travel light do not carry more than
you need don't have too much luggage
rather
just pack what whatever you need
so with that i would like to thank you
very much
for attending
i will be available on slack
if you have any questions
so
let's
have a look
okay no questions there now but again
thank you very much i'll be happy to
answer any questions if you have any
thank you
hello everybody
and welcome to room one at ndc oslo in
virtual
my name's leila porter this session is
tdd and the terminator an introduction
to test driven development now just a
quick note this is an introduction to
tdd if you are already a tdd whiz kid
you may want to pop over to any of the
other amazing talks happening right now
you've still got plenty of time if an
introduction to test-driven development
isn't for you
but if it is
then let's begin so
as i said my name's leila porter uh
welcome to my home office
my i am a microsoft mvp
i organize my local.net user group here
in milton keynes which is about
60 miles north of london
i love csharp and i am a senior
developer evangelist at twilio so uh if
you've not heard of twilio we're just a
cloud communications platform so you
feel free to find me on slack and ask me
some questions about it if you wish
but you're probably asking yourself
this question right now why tdd
and the terminator and that's a very
good question
and to answer that i need to take you
back to uh a previous job of mine was
quite a while ago now
and this was also at a communications
company and we worked on my team worked
on a cloud platform that allowed
carriers to manage communications and
like their rating and routing of
telephony so it's quite a complicated
system
so we worked on the platform that
allowed them to manage it
and
we relied solely on a team of six
testers
and by that i mean we didn't have a
single unit test not one no integration
tests
nothing we just about had uh uat testing
which is user acceptance testing um but
everything was based on this this team
of six testers
that worked out fine for me for a while
and then after one particular release
and our release cycles were sort of once
a year
uh we got to the point where we had nine
weeks
of regression bug fixing so just let
that sink in
nine weeks of development which was only
fixing regression bugs
it was a bad time uh and at this bad
time i thought there had to be a better
way of doing things surely this couldn't
be the way that quality software was
written and that's when i started to
research different ways of doing things
and i came across tdd or test driven
development i was like yeah this sounds
right up my street definitely something
i would like to watch oh and i've just
remembered if you're watching on youtube
you can also watch on webex just
remembered i was asked to say that and
it just popped into my head so uh this
is also on webex so feel free to watch
on there as well but anyway back to tdd
so i i thought this is a much better way
of doing things i'm going to learn how
to do tdd
or more to the point i'm going to
attempt to learn because that's what it
was
uh
i didn't know where to start i didn't
find tdd very accessible i felt the
learning curve was really steep
i tried reading books
that didn't help i tried watching
youtube videos and it was like magic
happening on straight on screen i also
watched pluralsight
and
nothing really helped i was like i need
something simple that i can build myself
that will help me relate to the issue
and that's what i did i'm a fan of the
terminator movies so i created my own
little tiny tdd
terminator app and i have rewritten that
and
revamped it a little bit and i'm going
to share it with you in the aims that if
you're stuck on how to get started with
tdd or it just doesn't sink in that this
may help you just as it did me
so let's have a look at
some tdd successes
and the first one of those is acceptance
criteria now
this is where you speak to the project
or product owner or your project manager
and you really get them to define what
the requirements for each feature are
and what does this mean really well it
means that you don't have any
wishy-washy requirements and you know
exactly what your code should do
and if you know exactly what your code
should do then it's very easy to write
tests for it
and so that's the first thing
um and this means that you have a
greater understanding of what your code
should do
and once you've written your code you're
not going to have your product manager
or product owner come up to and say well
i didn't mean for it to do that i
actually meant for it to do x y and z
so you save time and everybody has a
clear understanding of what should be
happening
so the next one
focus
now as developers we are prone to adhd
and uh
there's a term called shaving the yak
and i've got the link to a good blog
post on it at the end of the talk so
don't feel like you have to rush off and
google it now of course you could but
uh the phrase shaving the yak and once
you know what it means you'll be like
yes that's exactly what i do
and what a lot of us do is right i need
to implement this feature but hang on
to implement this feature i need to
write this bit of code oh but to write
this bit of code i need to update the
database and so on and so forth and you
just get on this endless to-do list and
you never actually get to do the thing
that you really wanted to do
so focus and this means that
you have
distinct pieces of code functionality
let's call it and you know exactly what
you need to do
to complete this little test so you
write a test or a collection of tests
and you say
oh okay if i fulfill this bit of code
that's it i keep focused all i have to
do is write some code that fulfills this
function and passes this test so you
don't go off anywhere else and looking
at other things you keep your focus so
that's really helpful
so the next thing we have is interfaces
and you may be thinking well what's that
got to do with tdd
now i'm i'm a practical
uh person so i have a very pragmatic
approach to tdd rather than dogmatic and
a lot of people you'll see and will be
like no you just write the bare minimum
of code
i like to write interfaces for my tdd
they're a coding contract and when i'm
working in a team i can actually say to
clara my teammate here's my interface
this is what i expect my code to fulfill
and if you need to get on with your code
this is what my code will fulfill even
though you haven't written any of the
functionality or the implementation of
that interface because you've written
your tests
and you know that your tests are going
to fulfill that interface okay
so this leads on to a really useful
aspect of tdd
and that's asynchronous development
and that means that i am not dependent
on
bob who's working on a particular
feature to finish finish his feature
before i can start working on mine
now at the old company where i used to
work
um
we couldn't go and just pick something
out the back clock it was really oh well
actually that needs this story to be
finished first and oh i need to make
sure that that's changed and that's
implemented so you're constantly picking
through the backlog and seeing what you
actually can do
rather than just grabbing one that fits
your time frame and your interest or
your skill set and getting on with it so
having
interfaces and proper small pieces of
code and all of the above will help you
be an asynchronous development team
and because you're focused and you have
coding contracts you have cleaner code
because you're only writing enough code
to pass a test
you're not going off and shaving that
yak and doing everything else that you
think you need to do you are simply
writing enough code to pass the test so
you don't get bloat or unnecessary code
or code where it shouldn't be you just
get lovely clean code
this one is one of my favorites safe
refactoring now remember those nine
weeks of fixing regression bugs i
wouldn't have had it if we had tests
because
if as soon as you regress your code
your tests don't pass so you get an idea
straight away that you have made a
regression bug and you don't have to
wait till release day to find out that
by working in a particular area you've
broken a whole
another area so safe refactoring is a
massive
factor for
tests and i will just put that caveat in
some of these things are
um
not just restricted to test driven
development but unit testing in general
so just having unit tests allows you to
have safe refactoring
so
that definitely leads on to fewer bugs
which everybody loves fewer bugs
and of course if you have fewer bugs
you're spending less time fixing bugs
and more time implementing new features
and and developing a better product so
you get increasing returns which makes
everybody happy
and the final point i'm going to raise
is living documentation
now
tests are not a replacement for
documentation however they are
a really good start if you have a new
developer join your team if they go and
read all of your tests which should have
descriptive names they can understand
what your code is meant to do and you
can also build your actual documentation
from your tests so it really helps in so
many different ways having tests
okay
excuse me
so let's go back to the terminator
and have a look at how we apply some of
these things to our terminator app
and the very first thing we want to look
at is the process
and what is the first thing in our
process
well that's gathering the requirements
let's have a look at how we're going to
gather our requirements
for our terminator app
okay
so we have a boy on a motorbike and
we're having a look at him we're
investigating him further
and we've actually identified him
positively as john connor and we we
really need to investigate john connor
further uh because he's a target uh so
from that we can derive a couple of
requirements and the first one is scan
subjects and determine if they require
further investigation
and the second one is
investigate subjects of interest and
determine if they are indeed the target
and then terminate them
we're going to focus on the top one scan
subjects and determine if they require
further investigation so that seems like
a really nice um
requirement to start with nice and and
succinct as well
so what we need to do now is start with
failing tests
and these failing tests um mean that you
haven't got any code written because you
can't pass tests if there's no code so
it's a really good start to
test driven development um
and this is important when you write
tests after coding you may be writing
them to fit your code and not your
requirements
and what i mean by this is imagine
you've written an api endpoint and it
returns
200 and content
and then you go and
write a test that
tests to see if your code returns 200
and some content
your tests pass everything you think is
hunky-dory but actually when you go and
look at the documentation it's not meant
to return 200 and content it's just
based your return of 204
and your tests have passed
and any thing you change will fail your
test so you know you think everything is
okay but it doesn't actually fit your
requirements so unless you're
cross-checking your tests with your
requirements
you could be writing them to fit your
code
now if you write your tests first the
only thing you've got to go on is the
requirement so you would look at your
requirements go right this has to return
a 204 and you write the tests to
check that it's returning a 204 so uh
that's a really valid reason for doing
tdd
okay
i like to use the red green refactor
pattern and what that means is we write
a failing test and we write enough code
to get the test pass so the failing test
is read when your test passed
it goes green and then we can refactor
and that's a really nice iterative
process that you can keep doing and
we're going to go over to code and have
a look at what that looks like so
let's go
this way
and here i have a
simple
application this is just built off a
template it's nothing
fancy
and i do have the github repo for this
as well which you can have the links at
the end of the talk i will just say uh
i'm not checking slack or anything if
you have questions please just uh save
them for the end and there'll be time at
the end for me to go through and answer
them
um so let's have a look at what i've got
in this code the first thing we're going
to look at is this interface called i
subject and this has one property
called subject name
i have an implementation of that
called subject
and pretty straightforward and then i
have an eye subject analyzer now if you
remember our requirement was should we
go and investigate a person further so
we've got this being a bull yes or no
and investigate further and we're going
to pass them in a subject
and over here we have our test class
now i use n-unit in this particular
instance i
i like n-unit
you could use x unit and there are many
arguments for using x unit because it's
more maintained um and it's more modern
uh you can of course use the microsoft
testing framework as well uh i've used
all of them i just happen to like n unit
and i put this one in here x unit is
very similar uh just slightly different
decorators but they all do roughly the
same thing
so what we have is test fixture here is
part of n unit and it's saying this is
going to be a test class
and once we go in here you'll see i have
this
private of i subject analyzer so that's
this interface here
and i've called that s-u-t and that
stands for subject under test
calling the class that you're testing
something such as s-u-t differentiates
it from
many other dependencies so
perhaps this class subject analyzer
is dependent on multiple classes
if i have all of those in here because
i'll need them
and they've all got their class names by
calling this sct it just keeps it clear
that this is the class that i'm testing
so it's just it makes life easier
next uh we have this setup and this is
where i can set anything up that i want
to use throughout all of my test methods
you can set stuff up in each
test method but if it's something you're
going to be using again and again it's
nice to set it up at the beginning and
this is where the frameworks differ
slightly i particularly like this way of
doing it with n unit so what we need to
do is actually create an instance of s u
t so we'll come here sct is equal to mu
and i don't have an implementation of i
subject analyzer so
all right we need to create one of those
so let's come over here to services and
i'm going to add one in here so we'll
have a new file and we'll call that
we won't have a new file we'll have a
new class
and we're going to call that subject
analyzer um i often get asked what ide
i'm using i'm using uh jetbrains rider
um i happen to
like this as you may have noticed i'm on
a mac and
i find it's really good for development
on a mac
it's very similar to visual studio with
uh
resharper on i like the testing
framework from resharper as well so um i
just happen to use it but it doesn't
make any difference to what we're doing
so
i've now got this class called subject
analyzer and it implements i subject
analyzer but it doesn't really implement
it because we haven't said implement
missing members
so what we do when we get an implemented
interface is we'll get something that
looks like this
and it says throw new system not
implemented exception
and that's absolutely fine we don't need
to change any code yet because we
haven't written a test yet so leave it
like this let me zoom in a little bit
for you and let's go back to our tests
so now that we've got the implementation
i can go new subject analyzer
and this is now ready for us to use and
test
so down here i've got our requirements
scan
subjects and determine if they require
further
investigation
and
so let's go and write our first test
and that's going to be a public
void
and what we're going to say is
terminator
should
uh determine
to
investigate
let's go look for sarah connor and let's
have investigate woman
further
okay
so
just a note on naming of
your test methods
many people will
delimit each word like so with an
underscore
i find that harder but you may prefer it
um but what i like to do is have what
what we're doing what the thing is what
it should do and then sort of the end
part so i like to divide it up into
three parts and you'll see as i name
more methods what that looks like
and
what we need to do is make this
discoverable to our testing framework so
this is with another decorator and this
is called test and you can see now i've
got this little play button here and you
can see it's going to run my tests and
we'll get to that in a moment
so
there's a few things that we need to
think about when we write a test and
that is
we need to arrange
we need to act
and then we need to assert
and
so the action is going to be actually
the test method so that is going to be
the result
is equal to
s ut
dot investigate further
and you can see that we've got a red
squiggle here which means we need
something in here and that's going to go
into our
arranged if we go look here it wants a
subject
so
let's create a subject bar subject
is equal to a new
subject
and let's initialize it here as well and
bring in the missing usings and that has
a subject name and let's call that woman
because we're going to look for a woman
as it says up here in our test
method and now we can pass that subject
in
and i happen to know that if we're
looking for people to investigate
further because we're looking for sarah
connor we need to
investigate a woman we see further in
case she's sarah connor
so then we want to go result dot
i use fluent assertions so that's going
to be should
be true
and i quite like flown assertions
because they're nice and readable
they're screwing that up a little bit
um but you don't have to you can use the
built-in um
assertions that we're going to have a
look at in a
a little bit we'll we'll use one of
those so result thought should be true
so very quickly someone can come along
and go terminator should determine to
investigate women further and we can see
what this is so let's go and run our
test now i'm going to run them from up
here first because it's the first time
we're doing them and i want it to go
through and of course it wants to do
that because i clicked run rather than
tests run unit tests
so
we've now got our testing
um window up here
and you can see everything's red so
we've got our red part of our red green
refactor which is perfect
um and you can see here it's looking at
the classes if i had more classes they'd
all be listed here and then inside the
individual methods and it tells you
what's wrong if i move that across you
can see that it says
it's not implemented which is exactly
what we would expect
so let's go back
to our class
and remember our number one rule
we only want to
implement enough
code to get our test to pass
now as i said i can't see slack but feel
free to all scream it out and slack if
you know the answer
and um
so
the simplest thing we can write here to
get the test to pass
is
return true
and that was a massive aha moment to me
okay i was like that can't be right
but
we come back now and if i run all the
tests down here
i'll let that do its thing
green
and that was like an amazing aha moment
for me that i just write return true
and that's the start of tdd so let's get
on
so uh let me zoom out a little bit here
we're gonna go and write another method
uh let's think about if we see a t1
thousand i'm sorry if you're not into
the terminator movies you're gonna get a
lot of jargon that you might not
understand
um
so
if we see a t1 thousand let's think
we're in terminator one now we're
hunting john and sarah connor so is a
t-1000 i know i've managed the movies
together but forgive me and um
we're not interested in them because
they're on the same side as us so let's
have a look terminator should determine
not to
investigate further and i'm not worried
what this particular thing is we're
going to say a t-1000
i've passed that in and now we're just
going to update this to be false because
we're not interested in investigating a
t-1000
all right let's run our code actually if
i run them all we can have a look at
what we've got down here you can see
it's already discovered that second test
and that one's failed so let's go and
write just enough code to get our test
to pass
so let's come back in here what i'm
going to do is just cut that and if
subject
dot subject name is equal to woman or a
lovely bit of string matching here and
we'll return true
otherwise we'll return false
and i will just say that i hope nobody
ever programs a terminator by string
matching
okay we're not going to do that um
but it works for demonstration purposes
so now we've got this let's run our
tests again
boom they're all green you're liking
this let's go back over here
so
now we've we've seen john connor so
that's a boy we want to investigate
further so i could go and copy this
whole method again and and paste it and
do it but it's going to get a little bit
tedious so what we're going to do is
update this method to take multiple test
cases
so let's start by renaming it who should
we investigate further
i'm going to change this decorator to be
a test case
and in here we're going to say a woman
and we can add as many test cases as we
want to hear
and you can have loads of them
and immediately if you notice down here
in our
test explorer i've now got this set of
sub tests under this one
terminator should determine to
investigate further so we've got two
tests in there boy and woman we've not
run those tests yet so they've got
question marks
and how we get those in is we add them
as arguments so string and we'll call
this one subject name
and then what we need to do is just
where we've got woman down here we'll
just say that subject name is equal to
subject name
and these are all going to be true
okay and we'll come to how we can update
this further and back in slides so let's
go and run all of our tests
and you can see the one for boy has
failed
so let's go back now you're probably
going oh why didn't you just do the
switch statement here or something but
that would break our rules we're only
writing enough code to pass our tests
and so i'm just going to do a really
lovely
and this is gorgeous isn't it folks
don't worry we will refactor
um
so that let's run it's just enough code
to get my tests to pass
hopefully
and there so you can see really clearly
how we've quickly started to build up
code and i'm not saying that this is
particularly nice code um but
we've got two tests
and we've written our code so let's now
go back to the slides and see what we
can do further so i'm going to go this
way
and
let's continue
so now that we've got the basics in
there and we've got our tests we can
start to safely refactor and this is
really key
and
let's go and have a look at what we've
got so imagine now i've added in um
tests for a girl and a man we want to go
and investigate them all so here's my
lovely stack of if
statements and
i've gone and made a switch not a fancy
new c-sharp eight-six switch
just a plain old basic switch
so we safely refactored that
and
if we have a look at our test case
our test class here you can see that
i've got all of those test cases stacked
okay
so
that all works and if i look at my uh
bottom class there the
terminator should determine not to
investigate further that's fine two but
now
requirement change
let's see what this one is
okay so sarah connor's doing something
funny with them the terminators
heads they oh this is interesting
and oh it looks like he can
learn things
now um if you have not seen the
director's cut of terminator 2 this will
be an unfamiliar scene to you this is
only in the director's cut and a little
bit of
trivia there is the head you see in the
foreground the back of the head is uh
arnold schwarzenegger's stunt double and
the arm is lindell linda hamilton's
sister so this hand closest to us is
linda hamilton's sister so just a little
bit of uh movie trivia there so they
switched his chip to from read only so
he can learn things
so our new requirements are protect john
and sarah connor from threats and an
ability to learn
so let's go back and have a look at our
code
so this all still looks fine we've got a
nice success it's green
um
but
we've got terminator should determine
not to investigate further
um
but now we want to because if we see a
t1000 they're a potential threat to john
and sarah so we need to investigate them
further
so if we update our
switch and say yes we want to
investigate t1000
we get this error expected result to be
false but found true
so now what am i faced with doing
well i'd have to go and modify my tests
but i don't want to so we should design
applications to be more robust because
we shouldn't have to go in there and
fiddle with things as soon as a
requirement changes that's tedious
and that's not why we have all this safe
refactoring and things
and to make software more robust
you can look at design patterns
um
now anyone who uh
has known me for a while will know that
my twitter
bio used to say
so solid
okay at the moment i am championing
black lives matter so i have that on my
twitter bio at the moment but previously
i had so solid because i am a big
advocate for solid but this isn't going
to turn into a solid talk so never fear
we're gonna have a look at them briefly
though
so in case you don't know what solid is
uh here it is it's the single
responsibility principle the open close
principle the lisk of substitution
principle
the interface segregation principle and
the dependency inversion principle now
we've already done some of these
um and we'll cover that in a moment but
we're really interested in the top three
seoul or the sunny side as i like to
call it
let's look at these closer
so the single responsibility means that
every class or module in a program
should have a responsibility to just a
single piece of that program's
functionality
now if you think about that from our
requirements
if you've got
multiple things happening in a class
multiple pieces of functionality how do
you test that
how do you know which is the failing
piece of this big method if i take you
back to the company i used to work for
we had controllers and with a
control their method in there that was
800 lines of code
and it had so much functionality going
on there you wouldn't even know where to
start to debug that we had break points
galore everywhere it was a nightmare i
wouldn't inflict it on my enemies
or maybe i would maybe i would but
anyway
so this is really key principle that you
just have that single piece of
functionality
and onto open close principle
software entities such as classes
modules functions etc should be open for
extension but closed the modification
what does that mean
when i first saw this i was like i don't
understand i don't get it how can it be
open for extension but closed for
modification i don't get it
well i'm going to show you in a moment a
sort of example of how this works that
can be amazing
for keeping your code in a really good
functional way that you don't have to go
and rewrite your tests or anything okay
we're going to do it in a moment
and the final one we're looking at is
the lisk of substitution principle
objects should be replaceable with
instances of their subtypes without
altering the correctness of that program
and that's going to be key for what
we're going to do in a moment
um
we've already seen that we can have
multiple
implementations of a certain interface
and the tests should all still work
similarly
so let's see this in action we'll come
over and refactor our code
alrighty
so this is what we've got
we've got our
terminator should determine to
investigate further and we've got the
four test cases
and then we have the one for the t100
that's t1000 rather
so i am going to rewrite those two tests
into this one test on the right hand
side
so what we've done now is we've added
some more arguments
and let's step through
so let's take that first decorator test
case and we've got woman and true and
they map to those two arguments string
subject name and bull outcome
and then
the subject name works just the same we
pass that into our new subject and then
the outcome
is in our results so this is now not uh
fluent assertions we're going into the
regular assertions and result dot equals
the outcome okay
so you can see there that we've actually
got the test case with the t-1000 we're
no longer going to investigate uh the
girl or the man we can put whatever we
like in here as many test cases as we
want and they should all
work in the code in the same way
and as you can see they do so we've got
all of those passing
based on our current code
so let's go and have a closer look at
how we can refactor this code even
further
so
let's see what we've got at the moment
we have our
public
bull method called investigate further
that takes a subject
and that currently has that rather
delightful switch
we have our i subject and we have our
implementation of i subject
and what i'm proposing we add
is this
now this interface down here in the
bottom right is called i subject rule
i'm going to create a rule set and we
can do all of this because we've got our
lovely tests in there first
and this has two methods is match so
does this rule match the subject name
coming in and then if it does is the
subject of interest
so let's now have a look at how we write
those rules based on our code
so on the left we have our current code
with the switch and on the right we have
our first implementation of a
an i subject rule and that's the is
woman rule if we look at our switch we
can say that if there's a woman is it of
interest and you can see yes it is we'll
return true
and then we've got the is match method
which will take the subject and using a
little bit of very dodgy link here it's
going to
have a look and see if that matches now
of course i know that if you um had
a man rule and you pass woman yes woman
contains man and it gets messy but just
forget that
this rule could be anything you could be
heading on over to cognitive services
and getting a
um
a certainty back from them on whether um
a subject is a woman and based on that
um
certainty going and investigating it
doesn't matter what this is match is um
it's going to work the same way so we're
just going to use um
string
matching here uh do not build a
terminator by matching on strings please
please
don't
um but it's good for demonstration
purposes
um so now we have an isdog rule and dogs
are lovely and
so we don't need to investigate them
further so you can see that our of
interest method is going to return false
here okay so we can go and pull out as
many rules as you like and they all have
to implement i subject rule that is the
key
so
i've got the
investigate further method on the left
and i have it on the right now
but you can see i've added some more
code to my subject analyzer class
and we're going to step through this
because you're thinking wow that switch
just looks lovely now can we not go back
to the switch no we can't we're going to
go through and have a look at how we can
refactor our code to be much more
extensible
so i'm going to bring up those rules on
the left and let's start to step through
our code and with those in mind
so the first and most important thing
we've added is this collection of i
subject rules and we've just called that
underscore subject rules
and it's very important that this is i
subject rules because now we can have
any implementation of i subject rule
added to this collection which is what
we do in the constructor so we've now
got a constructor
we have
we've instantiated subject rules
and you can see that's a new list of i
subject rule and now we can add
our
women rule
and our dog rule so
here is where you can do your extension
or your extensibility we can just keep
adding new rules okay
and we'll show you that in a moment so
let's go down and look at our
investigate further method the signature
is exactly the same so our tests should
work exactly the same
so we take that subject in
and the first thing we're going to look
at is
we're going to get a rule out of our
collection of rules we want to pluck the
relevant rule out so we use a little bit
of a link here and we use an expression
to access our is match rule from our
for example is woman rule on the left
and we pass in our subject and that will
either return uh true
or false and if it's
true we're gonna pluck that out and now
we've got our rules so say our subject
is a woman
we pass that into the investigate
further that rule is going to be true
and we get that is woman rule and then
we pass that rule into our investigate
further our investigate method now
that's a private method and we'll have a
note on private methods at a moment
so we pass that rule in and then we can
straight away call the of interest and
that will tell us whether it's true or
false and that means investigate further
will return true or false
so we've tidied that up very easily
without a big switch now i think if we
did use a switch and we had loads more
things that we needed to investigate
that's which is going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and we don't want that we've already
seen it grow from two to four and so on
um so we definitely
this this makes it a lot easier but back
to private methods
if you need to make a private method
public in order to test it then it's
time to refactor
now
imagine we're working asynchronously
and i have been given an interface by
clara
clara has implemented all of her stuff
using that interface and everything's
going great and i go well i really need
to test this private method here that i
need
so i'm going to add it to the interface
so i can test it
but i've just broken all of clara's code
and she's like well i don't need this
i'm not going to do an implementation so
she just leaves it as thorough new not
implemented exception
now i have seen
classes that have 20 or 30
of these methods with throw new not
implemented exception um and that's a
real code smell
it's
unnecessary code bloat now all your
tests well you can't write tests for
this because well they're not doing
anything they're all going to fail
um so this is really not great now if i
do want to make my private method public
i should write a second interface for it
which brings me on to the i in solid the
interface segregation principle and this
splits interfaces that are very large
into smaller and more specific ones so
that implementations will only have to
know about the methods that are of
interest to them so now i can implement
two interfaces on my class
but
clara just needs to implement the one
and we share that one but the additional
stuff that i need i just make a separate
interface for it
and so that's a really
tidy way of
being able to look after your code and
keep it clean and minimalistic
so
let's have a look at our code now so
we've implemented this change you see
we've got that collection in our
constructor
um and then down here we've got
our
public method the investigate further
and we've got our investigate private
method and now when we pass in those two
rules um test those test cases dog and
women you get it all passing
now as i said this is
extensible
it fulfills the open close principle so
it's open to extension but close to
modification
as i get new rules
all i have to do is add them to the
collection my code in investigate
further doesn't need to change it's
closed for modification we're not
modifying that any further but i can
keep adding new functionality
by adding new rules and and you may be
thinking where do i use this well i've
recently did this for a notification
handler uh so you could have
notification rules based on different
criteria what type of notification is
sent
so you don't need to go through an if
statements you just have a rule and and
it will go through and so it's a really
good way of making code totally
extensible
and with that good practices and
code management becomes infinitely
easier so you don't need to worry about
refactoring tests and refactoring your
methods you can just
extend
till your heart's content so that's
fantastic
um
so let's have a look at tdd failures and
this is specifically through
the learning of tdd and implementations
and things
and the biggest one is underestimating
the learning curve
so
if you think that you can pick up tdd in
a day
maybe you can but a lot of people are
going to be gay um
i don't know how to start
and so underestimating that learning
curve can be a real
issue and it can be really disheartening
as well if you think am i being really
stupid here is that surely this is easy
it's not it's a complete cultural change
a massive change to the way you think as
well
many people confuse tdd with unit
testing um so i've done twitter polls
and ask people well do you do tdd and
they're like yeah well i write my code
and then i write my unit test
now that's just testing it's not tdd
tdd is specifically writing those
failing tests before you write a single
line of code and
another failing is thinking tdd is
enough testing so my previous job we
were all tdd but we only had tdd with
unit testing
we didn't have integration tests we
didn't have
a testing team we didn't have uat
testing um
so we just depended wholly on unit tests
and tdd and i'm sure you've seen enough
memes about um unit test versus
integration test
uh not starting with failing tests
that's a code smell if your tests
immediately pass
uh then you know you probably haven't
written your test first because how is
your your test gonna pass
if you've not written your code
um
and then not refactoring enough being
lazy and not you know making that
private method public and tacking it
onto clara's interface and screwing over
her code
and you don't want to over engineer but
you want to make stuff uh
refactored enough to be maintainable and
obviously you know if something's going
to be changed again and again or or
hopefully with the scope and
basically the rule is you can refactor
something once and if you come to
refactor it a second time then you
should be thinking about what you should
make uh do to make it more maintainable
okay
um
and not actually doing tdd
i'm really um when i started i was
really
uh falling foul of this one so remember
we had that switch and i said just
return true well i wouldn't just return
true like well i need a switch here so
i'd write my big switch and then be like
i'll let my test passed and then right
what's my next test so i'd write another
test oh
it passed oh i've already written my
code so i'm not actually doing tdd
anymore i'm writing unit tests after the
fact so you have to be quite strict when
you do tdd
and you know that that's difficult um so
let's have a look at implementation
within your organization
it can be controversial and is a
significant cultural change
so
you may when you implement it you may
start to really slow down on your output
and your product manager is going to be
like what's going on why why is this all
changing so that can lead to an initial
drop in productivity which is my next
point but
it can be controversial not everyone is
going to be on board um so you need to
be kind and patient and help people make
the cultural change and it may be
that people just don't want to do tdd
certain members of the team and be
prepared that they're going to move on
um because it's not for everybody um
you know be be sort of
open-minded about things so as i said it
can give an initial drop in productivity
and that can be really disconcerting if
you've got a high performing team and
suddenly you've halved the
um
the number of stories in their sprint
uh or they you haven't halved it yet
you've got the same number of things and
they're now not finishing everything in
the sprint that can be disconcerting
they're like why are we so um
down on all of this
why are we not progressing still
so you know you really need to be
mindful that this could be a really
disconcerting time for your developers
but
if you stick with it and you get past
this lack of this drop in productivity
and you speak to your
product manager and tell them what's
happening
you will get a productivity
increase
it will go up and your
reworks will be reduced so you'll get
less bugs and you'll get faster and
faster and faster you have to be
prepared for that initial slump and
reduction in productivity
but once you're going
the productivity just skyrockets because
you're not creating all those blood bugs
so you get an increased understanding of
requirements and their acceptance
criteria so your relationship with the
product manager or the product owner
becomes far better because
you're saying no i haven't got enough
information here to write the code so
you're putting the onus on them to go
and
really think about how the product
should work what they need and then
coming back to you and going this is
what it should do so everybody has a
greater understanding so you won't get
those um
bugs where you say well this didn't do
what i wanted it to do
so
basically if you take one thing away
from this talk well let's say two let's
go back here um and think about the
implementation i just want to say be
kind and patient that's a really big
thing okay be kind and patient it's a
big culture of change um and don't
expect it to happen overnight and just
communicate with everybody
and that should go much better for you
so on to the if you take one thing away
from this talk and this is going back to
my big aha moment
and that's it you have code that looks
like this
you want to return true
write the least amount of code to get
your test to pass and if that means
return true
just return true okay
don't be afraid to do it this blew my
mind um every time i've given this talk
someone has come up to me and said
that was either
their aha moment when they learned tdd
or it was their aha moment within this
talk so i hope that that has helped some
of you
understand
tdd a little bit more and and with that
i want to say a huge thank you um to all
of you for joining me uh to every one of
the organizers uh to my host in the room
and and making what is a massive
conference that um i've been to the last
few years in oslo and taking it on to a
super interactive event online so
a massive thank you to everybody um so
here are some things about me you can
follow me on twitter uh leila codes at
uh this repo you can get on that bitly
link tdd terminator or you can find on
my github where it's layla hyphen p
this deck is available um
on that link there
i am on twitch i'm part of the live
coders team
um
so
you can watch me on twitch where i
predominantly talk about uh
azure functions on a monday and general
c-sharp on a thursday i will be adding
in some more uh scheduling as well in
the coming weeks so feel free to catch
me on twitch and as i promise if you
want to know more about shading the yak
you can check out that link
so awesome right i'm going to stop
sharing and bring up a slack on my
machine
so if you uh want to post any questions
in there uh feel free to ask me uh let
me come back now over to um
slack
um
welcome to this last session of andy c
oslo i am fully aware that i am the only
thing in between you and your weekend
but i'll try to make that journey as
as close as
nice as possible
now my name is marcus veggie and i work
as a software developer for aquino in a
team consisting of 13 developers
developing scientific computing software
um
and
we developed many different applications
one
being
what you could consider a legacy
application
now i could also talk about our more
shiny and new projects but to be honest
i think some of the most interesting
problems that we faces
that we face
both with respect to computer science
but also with respect to development
methodology
comes
from this legacy
projects
so
because of that
i'm here today to give you this talk
named strangling hydra one had
now
to give you a bit of context i am going
to tell you the story of
now
if you were hoping for
for it being a hydra then i have to
disappoint you and i think you would
have to try to find a movie instead
later tonight to uh to give you that
um
but dealing with legacy software it can
sometimes feel like you're chopping one
hat off when someone comes up that's a
different that's a different story
it is also
not about cheese
so for the non-norwegian or part of the
audience i can tell you that
is the norwegian word for p
which means that now you got to learn a
little bit of norwegian culture even
though you didn't get to go to oslo
now aft is an acronym for ensemble-based
resort tool and it was created
as a tool
to reason about the uncertainty in
reservoir models
because
in equinor
we are producing oil and gas from
reservoirs and the honest truth is that
no one has ever gone down and inspected
these reservoirs so
we have some idea about what they look
like but we don't know for sure so it
could be that it looks like this
it could also be that it looks like this
and it could be that it looks like
that it looks like this
there are various properties about a
reservoir that is interesting it can be
how well fluid moves through the
reservoir
it can also be what the reservoir itself
actually consists of so normally there
is some water at the bottom
and then there might be oil and gas
above
and as you might imagine we do very much
care where that line goes and it might
be like this
it might also be like this
and that is
key information for us
when we are to plan how to operate a
reservoir in the future
now what art allows you to do is to take
a model with uncertainty attached to it
and then basically just spawn a
multiverse a bunch of different
universes representing this model where
each and every one of these models is a
concrete model with
concrete knowledge that you can simulate
ahead of time ahead in time and by that
you can make forecasts run simulators
results etc
so this allows you to take all of these
different universes simulate them ahead
in time
and then use statistics to reason about
what you think will happen in this model
of yours that has uncertainty
this allows you to say something about
the future
but it also allows you over time to
compare what you are simulating on the
computer with what you are observing in
reality
and by doing so the hope is that you can
actually gain improved knowledge of your
system
now as the name dictates and these
examples show this application was
originally
made for dealing with
uncertainty in wrestling models but
today we are also using them for our
wind farms
we are using aft
to quantify the uncertainty of wind farm
models how the turbulence behaves under
different weather conditions and so
forth
so basically if you have something that
you can simulate but where the model
itself has some inherent uncertainty
then can be your two
now if you think that this sounds really
cool
then you alright luck my friend because
actually at nbc pack down last year i
gave a talk on the mathematics behind
so if you want to know more about that
then you can go to youtube and check out
that
but today we are to talk about
as a software project
and
started out with reservoirs
the need for software
someone had an idea that idea involved
into mathematics which again was
manifested in software that allowed you
to reason about this uncertainty
and
this was to a large extent developed by
a single developer
which is a massive feast
but it also has some interesting
consequences that i will get back to
later on
so we have users
scientists geologists
reservoir engineers
that starts to use this tool
to reason about the uncertainty in the
physical objects that they are modeling
and this actually imposed a pretty big
cultural change in the way that they are
working because then suddenly they had
to reason not only about the uncertainty
of the process that they are doing but
they also had to communicate this to the
ones using their results
and furthermore this uncertainty have
also had to be communicated to
management to really get the best out of
these tools
so
i imagine that
what they faced
in communicating this uncertainty
is quite similar to what we sometimes
face as software developers
when we are communicating
uncertainty around how long something
will take to make what we are making etc
and to be honest to give you a bit of
hope
it is actually today
as this program has been going for so
long
people with
the habit of reasoning about uncertainty
has also gone up into management and
sometimes
if someone is asking
for an estimate because they actually
need it to make an informed uh decision
i sometimes give them capability
distribution back and they are fine with
and i think that's awesome
so over time this provided the company
with a lot of value
because it actually improved our
knowledge of resource so more and more
fields started to implement this
technology
we got more users needing different
features from the software
and the software grew
more and more complex
we onboarded more developers to deal
with the project
and
i have to say that the process was very
much feature driven
which is a good thing
because it provided tremendous value to
the company
but
what it perhaps failed on to some extent
was to address that
so that accumulated in the project in
various ways
so for instance
we accumulated quite a bit of technical
debt
and as developers we experience and live
in that now and is dealing with that now
and
it basically says something about our
ability to move from where we are today
to where we want to be we are slowed
down
and we need to pay back and reorganize
our software to make it into what both
we and our users would like it to be in
the future
but even more so this technical depth
is imposing things on our users
so one of the consequences
is that they get quite cryptic error
messages
and
due to not always having coherent
feature design
we have actually ended up in a scenario
where sometimes
one user's feature is another user's bug
and
as you saw in the figure
we are to run simulations
but that goes beyond just a single
simulator we also have to take numbers
and encode that as a plan in the model
we have to reason about the model
afterwards and a lot of this is
happening on the compute cluster
but
quite a bit of it also happens on the
client side because you want to reason
about across all of these universes
and there is an api for doing this
but it's extremely complicated so
although
although our users can in theory do what
they
need to do
the complexity
and
inconsistency of the design of the apis
make very few capable actually
another very interesting thing is that
the work that the our users of this
software is doing
does in many ways
resemble the
process of us as software developers
they
they are
they are suffering from changing context
and they need to be able to focus they
have tremendous insight into the
physical object that they are simulating
to me that is one of the coolest things
about this project is
the enormous amount of knowledge that
our users have
but
due to that the system
is not always so easy to figure out
or that it sometimes gives you strange
error messages
what started out as being this vision
about how you want to model something or
how you wanted to quantify uncertainty
suddenly boils down to a cryptic error
message that no one no one understands
looking in the documentation trying to
figure out how to do something and they
lost this idea about how to mobilize
them
so although the tool itself is providing
a lot of value today
our vision together with our users is
that this tool should to a much larger
extent be a natural digital extension of
their workflow
another very interesting place where we
accumulate adapt in this project is with
respect to the knowledge
as i mentioned earlier
it was to a large extent a single
developer that developed this project
and there is this notion of a bus factor
of a project
which says something about how many of
your developers could be hit by the boss
today and the project would still move
on and that number was quite low
and this has many interesting
implications
one
being that a lot of this developers time
is tied up to this project because new
features are coming in
users need support
bug fixes etc
and since there are not that many others
to do it
this developer needs to do it
but
when you realize that you have a legacy
project and you want to deal with it
then
if you decide to do that by also scaling
up your team
then
you probably know that that is going to
cost you time and training which means
that you will have less time for
development
so even though it might pay off long
term it is a massive investment to grow
a team so you need to pay back by having
knowledge concentrated in few
individuals
i have a colleague oliver modon and he
says that the
individual learning isn't worth that
much learning needs to happen on an
organization level and i think that's
very much true
and it's something that we should be
conscious about
every day at work not only when dealing
with legacy software but every time
every time we are developing something
now there is also
a different perspective to this
and that is that sometimes we joke
that
being the only one that can develop
something or being one of the few that
can develop something is really good job
security
but i think that is a full premise
because not only is the developer's time
tied up to this project but the
success speed and pace of this project
is also tied up to this developer and
this developer is still just a single
developer or possibly a couple of
developers and there is a there is a
limit to how much they can do
so yes you have a lot of competence
about something that might not and there
might not be that many that have that
competence
but that
is still building on the hope that this
project will be a success
and
it will most likely only be a success
if you're able to have a good
development process and adapt as your
domain is changing the requirements is
changing maybe the i.t infrastructure
that you have you run on is changing and
you need to be able to deal with that
another thing that you have to address
especially if you are growing a team
is that you need to nurture your culture
i think we have a pretty good starting
point there in software innovation but
still when you bring up bringing new
people i've we have grown our
team by more than 50 percent
you still need to make sure that the
culture is
even maintained but also improved over
time and this is also an investment to
make sure that you're all pulling in the
same direction
but also to ensure that
every team member feels
safe
and trusted so that they can tell you
when they know something
say this is a bad idea i think we should
do something else
or tell you that
i don't know this i don't understand
what this means can you please explain
it to me
only by having that kind of culture can
you build a team with a lot of knowledge
around what you're doing
and
i think it's very interesting this
perspective of building
a team with different features and
strengths and you don't have to be good
at everything but you should probably be
good at something and it should
hopefully be that some of the
some of the
things that you need to do your job
so
as you get better
as your team gets better at doing what
they are doing which is probably
software development
i think we need to accept that you can't
get better at everything simultaneously
and on this thing i think we can learn
quite a bit from sports science because
they have a lot of theory on this and
they have this concept called
paradisation
where you accept that some features
of you as an athlete or your team can't
be improved at this point because you
want to focus on something else
you might even have to accept that
i will get slightly worse at this but at
the expense
or
to become much much better at something
else
and
you can
envision it being a bit like a
computer game where you have some
character or in this case a spaceship
that has various features
and then you can decide to improve this
part of your spaceship this part of your
character and then
as a team you might have to accept that
we can't fix everything at the same time
because we can get much better at this
right now and then we can try to get
better at something else afterwards
now
so when you start
when you start dealing with a legacy
application
then
i really believe that you need to get
the foundation right first
and
by this i mean
that you need to get your divorce right
you need to be able to deploy your
software in an automatic fashion in a
reproducible fashion and in a safe
fashion so that when you make iterations
you're able to get that out to your
users
i remember when i started working on
this project
then
a large fraction of the new new versions
deploying them would break the entire
system
and i mean this isn't the live system
nothing stops up
our money stream doesn't stop
if this software stops up
but
we are simulating things on an hpc
cluster
and these simulations can take quite a
bit of time and there are iterations on
top of these simulations where you're
adapting and changing the parameters to
your model
so
in reality our users can lose days and
days of work if we go down
and sometimes that doesn't bother them
that much just a little bit but
sometimes they are generating statistics
that are to go into decision making and
maybe that decision has to be made soon
and then they are not so happy
so we need we really needed to get our
deploys right and i think you do as well
if you are to deal
with legacy software
you also need to spend
time caring for your tests with
we were quite lucky we had a good test
with already or at least a decent one
um
but you need to be able to make sure
that when you are iterating and changing
your software
that correctness
and behavior still preserved
otherwise you will have no chance of
being sure
that the the changes that you are making
will also
keep the software
doing what it should do
and i think the last thing that you need
to do was very surprising to me
but you
you need to
learn to communicate with your users
especially in a complex domain
there is a tremendous difference
between both learning the language of
your users and also having them learn a
bit of your language lingo effectiveness
of that communication is just on a
different scale than what you have to
begin with
and if you want
to get a good description of what you
should make
what
challenges your users are facing
you have to be able to communicate with
them if not then you're living in a
vacuum
and when you've gotten this done
then you can start looking at the
architecture of your system the
different components
and their responsibilities
and sometimes
the boundaries aren't that
well defined
maybe responsibility might be shared
between different components that
shouldn't share this responsibility
maybe everything is talking to
everything
there is no good structure
but you need to figure out how it is
working and how they you need to get a
realistic image of the architecture
today
and then you need to figure out how you
would like it to be
in the future
and then
you need to start
making some first steps towards how you
would like it to be
this doesn't say that you should follow
this plan or that this doesn't change
you have to adapt as you learn and as
you go
but starting without the plan i think is
really naive as well
and also you have to accept
that you might have to go through some
hurdles and do some
not so pretty solutions
on your way towards what you want your
solution to be
sometimes when i talk about legacy
software to non-software developers i
compare it to building a road network
and you have like a road with a lot of
traffic
and
and then you are to do something with
that road i don't know build a
build a roundabout or a traffic light or
something
and you need to get the traffic over
somewhere else to be able to do this
this work so you might have to actually
create the temporary road they do this
they create temporary roads to redirect
traffic so that they can do what they
were supposed to do and then move the
traffic back again
and when you've planned your first steps
and figured out what
what you would like it to be
at least with your current knowledge
then you need to find
some components that you can start
working on because you can't do
everything at the same time you need to
start somewhere
and
there can be many ways of finding out
where you should start
it probably be good to find something
that is
sort of an easy win not the most complex
part of the system
it can also be about in which parts of
your system
do you expect changes to be able to make
the
system that your users want if you see
that
our users would really benefit from this
kind of feature and that will happen in
this part of the software
then it's much faster to start with that
part and starting with a part that you
don't really foresee changing that much
in the upcoming uh
future
you need to figure out where to start
then you can start implementing that
part of your new system
and starting to redirect and utilizing
features from that part as it gets made
and
it is easy to get lost in this kind of
uh work
so you really
need to make sure that the new stuff
that you're making
is good has high quality and
allow the developers
to make
to make something
that
so that they don't lose sight of what
good quality is they suffer from severe
quality fatigue i'll get back to that
later one
and when you start making these changes
you should
as always encapsulate these in like
small deliveries
and hopefully you can make many small
deliveries
and you can only do these changes if you
already made sure that your tests with
is decent
if not then you will stumble already
here
and afterwards
you need to make sure that these small
deliveries actually get out to your user
which means that and you need to do that
often as well you want each of these
small deliveries to actually reach out
to your users
and you won't be able to do that
without dealing
with and ensuring that your deploy
system is good
so if you if you fall in the trunk of
starting to deal with a code without
having the the necessary tooling the
true scripts and
tests
ready
and that will really come back to bite
you
and also you need
these deploys to actually get to the
users and to get to the users often
now one of the
one of the challenges with this when
you're dealing with refactoring and
rewriting code and managing legacy
systems that you want to
modernize
is that many of these changes
at least at the
bottom level of your application might
not even hit the users they might they
should hopefully not even recognize it
while you're just starting to pull it
apart and figure out how it should be
like
so now maybe you need to rethink what
your user is maybe your user actually is
a
colleague a developer in your team that
is now consuming your new api
or
utilizing a new feature that came up or
a more coherent
fashion of interacting with this module
and then you should make sure that your
deliveries actually reach out in their
development environment and i get that
you can get feedback
and if you are to get feedback both from
the users
and from these developers
then you need to have established this
language of communication so that you
can understand how
changes are impacting them or
what kind of
features they would like to see in the
future so that you know where you should
start addressing the legacy of your
system
so you need to get that in place
also
i have to say that
when you're dealing with technical debt
and knowledge that that there are times
as we mentioned where you don't
necessarily deliver that much new
functionality to your users because
you're dealing with the depth of the
system
and this
really requires
a great deal of trust between you as
developers the users and the product
owner
spending time on nurturing that
relationship
and
understanding their needs and explaining
the consequences of the work you do
today and what it will enable you to do
tomorrow
i think that is a really important
conversation to have
now as i am
i mentioned earlier
you really do need to manage relativity
if you're operating in a lot of
technical depth
you might
over time to avoid becoming crazy
actually
lower your standard of
what you think good quality is
when you start strangling your software
and
making new modules
really make sure that they are as good
as you possibly managed to make them
right now
you need to create these happy zones
safe places in your project
that
has
maybe even a higher quality than what
you hope that the system in total will
have something that really separates
the quality of the new parts from the
quality
of the old parts
also
you should really make sure to don't
let your colleagues get lost in the
wilderness of legacy code
we have something like one and a half
million lines of code in cn python
and sometimes
you start out with something that
appears to be an easy problem
and then you
and
and then you start addressing that
problem
you disappear down into the code and at
some point
you lose track of what's going
on you get so focused on the problem
that you're trying to solve but you
forget about your
implication of what you're doing to this
to design maybe you're
you're imposing
changes to the design of the api that
makes
it makes it less coherent than what it
was
maybe you're adding strange things to
the
build scripts to uh
avoid the hoops no to to get it working
and then you don't realize because
you're so focused on the problem that
you're trying to solve
and
in addition
in aquino we have something called
playground time and i think that is also
a very useful tool to actually manage
quality fatigue
so then you get to spend some time to do
something completely different
just learn new techniques
and new new technologies
i think it's really important to
recognize that both
by setting a really good standard in
these new parts of the project
as well as
doing for instance this playground time
that will really help you back into
managing the rest of the computer system
now
to cite multi-folder
um
it says let's face it
all we are doing is writing to moore's
legacy software
today and i think that's true
and i think we need to embrace it
and honestly i think maybe that's even
the most positive spin
the most positive view you can have on
this
because if you're not
writing
like you see
right now then you are
most likely writing a software system
that over time will not be relevant and
then just disappear again
of course you will have to manage your
debt
and improve it and make it make sure
that you can iterate on top of your
project in the direction you wanted to
go in
i think you also need to embrace that
you are writing legacy software right
now
i read this quote about growing up you
know some some weeks back i didn't
manage to find it again but basically
points that boil down to that becoming
an adult is becoming is coming to peace
with that the people around you are
nothing but humans i think maybe we need
to do the same as developers
we need to realize that
the code that you are screaming over
today was written with good intentions
and
maybe even was a very good decision at
the time when it was written
but tooling changed maybe
maybe new
new solutions came around we learned
more about software design or about
interacting with our users maybe the
domain changed completely
and or maybe the idea of their entire
writing system change and you want to do
something else
so i see that i have uh
banned a little last time and i was
planning to but
i now get to conclude my talk that is
the benefit of being a speaker then you
get to conclude
um
so
i we need to leverage that wisely and
that goes
for all software projects if you want to
move and get somewhere then
accumulating that might be the fastest
way to get there and the best way
together
maybe you should just prototype a
feature see how it goes maybe it isn't
relevant who knows
so implement it get it out get some get
some feedback but be sure that you also
are aware of that and that you manage it
or let someone on your team
dig deep down into some topic
that you might think um will be relevant
for how to solve a problem that you're
currently trying to deal with in your
team
let them learn something and figure out
how something works and maybe even
implement the solution
but make but then also be aware that
that knowledge
gained by that person is currently only
living there so make sure afterwards
that that knowledge is then flooded back
into the rest of the teeth
it allows you
to move quickly but you also need to
mitigate afterwards
also
if you are dealing with a legacy project
and then
i will highly encourage you to strangle
your hydra
iteratively
it's extremely
difficult
and
maybe even impossible i would say
to do everything at once
you need to iterate your implementation
and
make sure that changes that you are
doing
that's to your users in a good fashion
and then you can iterate on top of that
again afterwards
and last
realize that the code that you are
writing today
is the legacy of tomorrow
and make that legacy the best you can
i think that we have
quite a tendency to be aware of
abstractions when we are designing
software we try to do this of course
they start leaking over time and maybe
it gets
it shifts as the domain
evolves and so forth
i think we try to but i think we as a
community try to do that quite well
today
but
i'm a bit
i personally feel that we
sometimes today let the architecture
leak too far into our software solutions
i'm not saying that that shouldn't
happen because that's what architectural
decisions are we're making big
fundamental decisions
for your software project
it will
by its very nature be costly to change
but that doesn't mean that you have to
let it flow
into every single piece of your code so
i think that
is something that i hope we as a
community will
find even better ways of dealing with
even
in a
cloud native kind of architecture
in the future
and
last but not least this project is
actually open source you can check it
out
i think that is also one of the things
that you need to embrace when dealing
with the legacy code i mean
it is legacy because it provides a lot
of value so that's really really cool
um and also you have to identify with
the direction of the project and what is
currently going on
and by making that very good the
direction of your project if you're done
also in addition apply time
then
in the end you will be able to make an
impact
on the state of your project
and that is what i have to say
thank you for listening
and
yeah feel free to shoot questions
you